welcome back everybody for the feed a
online world corporate chess
championship when all is said and done
there will only be one
i am joined by anna kremling anna great
to have you today are you excited for
the finals
i'm super excited for the finals i mean
this seems to be the best day to join
this commentary so
it's an honor once again to do
commentary with you robert it's been a
while but i always really enjoy doing it
same here and it's going to be a fun
event because there are only eight teams
remaining
and those eight teams are vying for a
world championship title let's remind
everybody
of the new format because we're out of
the group stage so we get here
there will only be one team winning this
event
so for the pairing purposes the teams
were ranked one through eight according
to their average team
rating the quarter and semi-finals will
just have one match like we've seen
before
the finals will be a dual match two
matches you play your four games you get
a little rest you go back for four more
and if there is a tie the tie is broken
with
a blitz game three minutes two second
increment
and if the blitz match is drawn there
will be an armageddon game so can you
believe that not only is there a team
competition anna
but there could also be blitz in
armageddon what kind of pressure does
that put them under
armageddon always puts a lot of pressure
um
it's really difficult to know if you
would rather play white or black that's
sort of like a preference but
armageddon basically means playing a
game that's gonna be full of pressure
and
doing that in a team that just adds more
pressure because
all of a sudden your result doesn't just
affect yourself but it also affects
the whole team so that would definitely
be something very exciting
absolutely let's tell everybody who
these eight teams are we have the
bracket
you can see their rankings by average
team rating they all
won their groups you see spare in the
top left taking on erg
spare bank trade union taking on empty
solutions in the 4-5 match up
morgan stanley hungary taking on pt pelo
buhan
tanjuk priyak and gronke bank taking on
anahuak there in the bottom right
and as the games get underway let's look
at the matchups just a broad overview
here
of the teams and their players there are
grand masters including
super gm yon napomnishi up there for
spare
you have uh york meyer for gronkey bank
but let's go to the games let's move on
to the games there um as they are
beginning so let's start with none
another then
jan upon shiana has the black pieces
against anuar
is a grand master playing
g6 out of the spanish so what do you
think about this and
is jan just trying to get a kind of less
familiar
position he's playing a strong opponent
but maybe he feels the pressure to win
i think so um especially with the white
pieces i think that
he at least feels the pressure to
to draw um can you explain what the
white pieces are
and but once again nipoy is a super
strong player i mean he's one of the
best players in the world
so it's gonna be really tough it's
really cool to see
these very strong people playing in this
tournament
because every team can have one free
agent so
it's really really exciting to see the
super strong uh
players playing here and yeah now he's
going for c3 a6 is this theory robert
yeah it's so kind of like it's funny
because playing like a sideline
in a way but theory within that sideline
and at the super grand master level they
kind of know
not everything they're not full perfect
information at all times but
they know most of these sidelines here
and look at this move bishop e2 you've
given up a pawn in the center
and then drop the bishop back but the
reason white is going for this is
ideally
you get to take back on d4 with your
pawn and have a beautiful center
or if you take on c3 knight takes e3
white has three minor pieces out
compared to
one for black maybe we'll see a bishop
g5 a quick castle
and that's how black can get under
attack yeah so
typically when white goes for a gambit
that's sort of the idea that at least
they want to get something
for the pawn and um attack and
peace development i guess it's what
they're trying to go for in this
position here
so it's uh it's quite common to be
giving away sometimes this this d4 pawn
in different openings
and now we can see that black is going
for d3 so
black is giving back the pawn but
perhaps slowing
a bit the development for white that's
absolutely true and
this pawn on c3 blocks the knight's jump
out so that's why young gives the pawn
back sometimes it's not worth
stealing the material if it comes to
such a cost of giving white that rapid
development so let's uh
we'll keep an eye on this game we'll go
around to some others as well
i see that anton korobov is playing a
very strong grand master from ukraine
representing the spare bank trade union
and in this position i caught my eye
because there's a queen on h4
and i know we may be familiar with ideas
like this some of our viewers may not
it looks kind of scary for black right
with a queen on the king side
definitely i mean every single time that
there's a queen on the king's side
you have to have a look up for it and
just like you're saying that h7 pawn
could become
a weak point i don't know if at some
point there could be any ideas of going
knight g5 and trying to push for e5
somehow that could definitely be uh that
could definitely lead to some sort of an
attack
but it seems like uh varkomsky is going
for
for an attack and we'll have to see if
kraboff can defend this
and one of the ways to fend off an
attack is by striking back toward the
center it
seems counterintuitive right if i'm
getting attacked on the king side don't
have to put all my pieces there
but if you can attack in the center then
white's pieces
cannot just go free on the king side
they'll have to respond so b6 played
that looks like a slow move with a queen
on h4 but knight g5 for example
doesn't threaten the checkmate just yet
and maybe black has time to just play h6
anyway
and black is trying to play bishop to b7
maybe knight to c5
it's all about timing you can't just
make these moves without thinking
because white
will try to push an e5 type of move at
some point
but korboff's so experienced he
understands that for now he's all right
and the
evaluation bar says just as much
yeah exactly so we
yeah so he can't really go knight to
five yet just like you said and
there will have to be a sort of correct
move order if there's going to be any
attack here
but um going bishop b7 i think that's a
that's a great move placing the bishop
on b7 just to have this full diagonal
and like you said
try to take a bit control of the center
counter attacking in the center that's
what you want to do
if white is attacking on the king's side
so
uh i think that this definitely no
direct attack yet but i think it could
lead to some really interesting
positions this game
that's right and i'm gonna go to one of
the games in the
match of we have pt um
playing against morgan stanley hungary
and so we're gonna switch matches here
uh to show this game on board four
chelsea monica who streams
who is 22.50 playing against
international master ryosuke nanjo
japanese international master
very strong matchup here and the last
one play was b4 so this position out of
sicilian
white has thrusted g pawn off the board
black has put his b
pawn so anna you look at this position
right black
kings and center white king the same
what to make of it
i think it looks like a pretty crazy
position um it's like the type of
position where
you know any player could sort of if
they play a little inaccuracy that could
really
change the whole game and but
i don't know if they if they have
prepared us i can see that chelsea
that monica she's been thinking for a
little bit so i don't really know if she
if she had prepared for for a position
like this but i'm really happy to see
her
playing in this tournament just like you
mentioned she's a fellow
streamer on twitch and you know she's a
great streamer and she's also a very
strong chess player
so it's really fun to see her playing in
this tournament and playing in this
match
definitely and knight d1 you know while
she's of course experienced and she may
be familiar with some of the ideas based
on clock management thus far
it feels like black sort of has the
upper hand and what worries me
is white has nowhere to castle because
you put a pawn on g5
on the other side the board you put your
pawn a4 so your king could get caught in
the center
whereas black could play bishop e7 and
castle into an impending attack
but at least your king if it needs to
can get out of the center so that
concerns me
typical ideas like d5 at some point for
black maybe right now
look pretty decent for a riosuke nanjo
and
i don't know this is starting to look
pretty good for morgan stanley hungary
on board four yeah i totally agree with
you
and that point is a very good point that
you're making that white is going to
have a very difficult time castling
if white will probably not be able to
castle the king's side and castling
queen side also seems very dangerous
whereas black
just has the simple idea of going bishop
e7 castling and then
perhaps attacking the king and d5 is a
great move as it opens up the center
which is something that you would want
to do when the king is still in the
center and can't
hassle yet that's how this game could go
like d5
bishop b7 everything breaking open and
oftentimes
with a king in the center oh that move
was not engine approved but
the engine isn't exactly on the highest
depth so sometimes it takes a while to
register
but d5 i think was the thematic move it
would have protected this pawn on b4 as
well
not that you mind that pawn being
captured because if the queen takes it
then move like d5 will hit the queen and
open the sender so this is
actually going to be a very tense battle
i think it's going to come down to
white's king safety
but if she could stabilize she will have
the advantage
and whoa that move not appreciated by
the engine at all
going up to plus two point something so
there must be some tactic
and i think it starts with f4 kicking
the knight
and you can even think about f5 or even
e5 to close down the center
and then play for an attack from there
there being many tempos
won by white now after knight went to e5
if the black knight wouldn't have gone
g5 then moves like f4 would not have
been possible but she's going for a5
instead here
makes sense right hitting the knight on
b6 i think one of the things that can be
difficult is like move order and figure
out wait do i attack that knight or
attack the knight to center
do i attack both and you can mix up
ideas not because
these are very strong chess players
they're titled chess players but the
problem becomes when they're too many
attractive options in a position
we sometimes go for both and maybe only
one works at a time
yeah you know have you heard about all
these stories of
some super gms not knowing which rook to
take and thinking
or super long about you know if they
should take rick h d1 or
or go rook 81 in some positions and
there's the story with old anderson that
he played a correspondence chess
and you know it took him one week to
decide which rook he was going to bring
to d1 because there were so many
different opportunities
so it can be tough to to know what move
order to choose
that's an amazing story of anderson of
course a legend
of chess and one of the best players uh
in his generation so if he
took a week to decide maybe that would
mean a month for all of us and
well there was a capture on d5 recapture
but i was talking about white's king
being unsafe
now it's looking like black's king
because f4 is coming the d5 pawn's under
attack
even if the king does get castle to g8
still doesn't feel that safe so i think
we should leave the players to figure it
out on this board we'll go
within this match i see that muhammad
ludwi ali
the international master on board one
with a black piece against international
master lavon bergadzi that's the cool
thing
about this tournament all these teams
are very strong the average team rating
for
each team in the uh playoffs is
at least 22.70 i think it goes from 2270
it's like 24 something
and remember three of the four players
are members of that company
our work employees there rather so their
employees are very talented chess
players
and anna in this position we see the two
bishops for white
but white is down upon and the entrance
is zero so of course that means a dead
draw
right well
more than a dead draw i would say that
it means that there is
there is enough compensation for white
so if white is upon down but the engine
says that it's equal
it typically means that the activity
that white
has um equals
one pawn so that means that white has a
lot more activity
and has and has compensation for that
pawn basically
so i definitely don't think that this is
gonna end up in a draw just because of
that
you know just one of my quick comments
about how the engine can mislead us and
to think about
zero the players are not thinking in
this way they look at this position
and if you're international master ali
here you're saying well i have an extra
pawn so maybe i can
figure out how to free my pieces up and
use my material advantage
and international master brigadzi saying
your pieces can't move my rook's coming
to d7 my bishop on e4 is fantastic
attacking the knight on c6 and that pawn
on b7 behind it while protecting c2
and this bishop on b6 taking away d8 no
truck trades for you
protecting f2 if they were ever to be in
trouble i think it's easier to play this
position
from the white side if i'm being honest
yeah absolutely and i think that this
sort of comes to
what type of player you are some people
like to be upon down have a little or be
a pawn up have a little extra material
and just try to defend the whole
position and you know just basically say
you are not going to be able to win from
this position i'm going to defend until
we get into an engineer where i'm upon
up whereas other people really like
playing upon down but having a lot of
activity because
then their pieces are a lot more active
they can sort of pressure their opponent
down
and it's i think it's more a matter of
preference what what you
prefer well i prefer being up over two
minutes on the clock so i do like
white's position
uh even without the clock situation but
especially taking that into account it
looks dangerous
we do have results i'm going to go over
to that match and spare
because jan napomishi has been held to a
draw or you could say
held his opponent to a draw but i'm a
little confused because this position
looks anything but drawish this is a
wild position
so uh just getting word to see
who offered this draw you know it looks
like black made the final move
but why is this a draw this king is in
the open
white has one fewer rook but also one
extra minor piece and this attack right
move like knight to e4 can start
so a bit surprised that a draw offer
would be
accepted at this point yeah i'm a bit
surprised too i don't know if it has
anything to do with the fact that
well white is a bit better because of
the whole the whole attack and you know
all the pieces and everything
so i don't know if white was just
content with making a draw because they
were playing against
nippo and sometimes that's sort of the
case
they're playing against a super strong
player but i definitely think that if
white had the opportunity that they
should have kept on going here and
that's a grand master of the yp's in
a single game of course anwar can beat
jana palmache so
surprising to us but let's keep going
within this match we have
board two is alexander kadetsky taking
on
uh yuri
i'm trying my best i haven't studied my
rush in a long time so anyway
in this position you see that even
by material all four minor pieces on the
board but look at this jumping into this
f5 square
because the queen protects the knight
that could be a problem for black trying
to figure out which bishop do i give up
do i take on f5 giving up the light
square bishop
do i allow white to take on g7 giving
the dark square bishop
or maybe i should just retreat my bishop
to f8 which is played but then the e5
pawn
that feels like more of a target that is
definitely
going to be a target and i don't even
know if you could perhaps
take advantage of the fact that the
bishop is on g3 and it's spinning this
pawn on e5
and go something like knight d4 to
really exchange
black's pair of bishops oh actually
knight d4 looks like an excellent
good call the pawn is not just under
attack but it's pinned so at knight
f5 there it is a good call and a knight
f5 to d4 trying to get this bishop and
he can't move so
black's king is the worst of the two
there's more space that's
available for white's pieces in front of
it if you say take on d4
knight takes d4 then i'll take your
bishop play bishop g4
come after you on the diagonal this
looks very scary
yeah i definitely really like this for
white
um so we can see you know how annoying a
pin can be
that pawn and e5 would have stopped the
knights from from ever going to d4 but
because the pawn is pinned
and the queen is on c7 um why
it's allowed to play this and this looks
great and that's great for spare because
yonder palm she held that draw in a
tough position and now they're bored too
with the white pieces in great shape so
that could be a lead for spare but let's
see what's happening on board three
because
maxime lavrov with the black pieces um
well he's up how many pawns
it's only one pawn it looks like more
but this should be
a winning position for black sometimes
one pawn is not enough
but anna here it looks like the pawn
structure is better for black you have
more material
so it shouldn't be too difficult yeah
especially they have also the same color
bishop
um if there would have been different
color bishops perhaps
white could have tried to exchange queen
somehow and then go for that end game
which is a bit more difficult to
to win with different color bishops but
because they have the same color bishops
as well it's probably going to be quite
easy for black to win this
and one of the ideas is okay white can
go and try to take these queen side
pawns and then black would play h4 h3
and actually try to checkmate the white
king and this bishop on f1 is
bad another idea is queen e3 check queen
f2 and you actually might trap this
bishop weirdly enough it just doesn't
have much space
so the bishop on e6 is excellent the
bishop on f1 is actually quite bad
very few squares to work with so i think
this is going to be a win
for spare and if they win this game and
cadets get a great position
they will take the match so we'll keep
our eyes out
just be on the lookout but let's go on
to other games
where we haven't uh checked in on this
game between
fyodor mishakov and voracek raza
what's happening this king is castled on
c8 and a queen trade is being offered
and white's turn so and do you think you
should keep the queens on the board your
king
is in the center for white or should you
just trade them and have the two bishops
in an end game
well i think that in this exact position
the queen doesn't really have a
have a lot of squares to go to where it
wouldn't be traded
so the only place i can see where the
queens would not be traded would be to
go queen g3 but
because the king is in the center and
you know the bishop would be pinned on
e2 i think that it makes more sense to
at least offer a queen trade again so
you can see bishop f3 now white is
offering a queen trade again and they're
trading queens here that's right this is
board three match up between enfie
solutions and spare bank
trade union and the queens have been
traded the pawn has gone to e3 for what
look at this
pawns in the center here they're in red
because that's how black is seeing them
like oh i don't like that that's that's
painful
but f5 what a way to strike because if
e5 look at this bishop on d2
the dark squares are clogged by white's
pawns and that's why
white takes an f5 to keep the bishops
open but now the e file is open
maybe black has some counter play or
anna do you think that white should just
be able to increase the pressure i think
that
that bishop pair is going to be very
strong for white now the bishop is
pinning the knight on d6
and it feels like black is a bit
restricted with with their movement this
bishop is going to
e7 and perhaps black will have some
ideas of going g5 but then that will
give the e5 square for the bishop
so i feel like white's bishops are
really really strong and the king while
the king is now castling so the king is
gonna be safe
white is also gonna be able to take
advantage of the e file being open
and i really prefer white here i agree
and one thing that was almost there for
black was bishop h4
rook h4 g5 the problem is it's not a
fork
because white can get away with bishop
takes d6 with check
and end up a piece up otherwise this
would be a great decision for black
did not work out because of the check
and so g5 was played and oh
gosh now rook's on the seventh rank you
have the bishop pair
i think a material is about to fall
that's what it looks like you can just
slide your other
the e1 oh didn't like that move because
g4
g4 and bishop g5 check and the rook on
h7 is not defended
wow oh no that's how everything is
taking a turn here
and that's a big problem because after
g4
and it's played yeah that's a big
turnaround and it was looking
so nice the rook should have went to h1
to reinforce the other rook
and now after g4 that rook is not
protected and bishop g5
is a i mean how is it can you stop it i
don't see any way
i guess you have to take on d6 ah okay
so you don't lose material because
bishop b6
bishop d6 we trade rooks and then i
guess black is slightly better because
the advanced pawns but it is opposite
color
oh but it's not going just wait that's a
piece
that's a piece that's just the piece
wait wait but there's
what okay didn't take it because i guess
this ensuing end game it was the bishop
pair that looked nice
now there's g okay but g takes f3 rookie
seven check
king c8 this pawn's under attack neither
side feeling that comfortable in this
tactical
situation but black had that if it had
just taken on f3
instead we have a slightly better
position for black because the knight
can go from color complex to color
complex the pawn a6
could become a target in the near future
but ana that was
a pretty wild tactical sequence and it
felt like the players
were not ready for it definitely i
totally agree this was
definitely a very exciting tactical
sequence
and i think that neither have neither of
us saw that coming which
probably um reza didn't really see
either when he played rookie one
so yeah it was really important to go
rook h1 and reinforce the other work
there on on h7 he seemed to have a great
position before
but now it has turned around and
mishakov is going to be the one that's
going to try to go for the win here
for sure that a6 pawn is weak i have to
go to this game because i see two
seconds left
an internationally clogged and now down
in exchange so it looks like
morgan stanley hungary is going to take
this all i am match up on board one
that apon is running very easy to keep
pushing it a6 rook b7
a7 you're gonna win this bishop so i
just saw a couple seconds remaining and
as we tuned in
it looks like white was winning material
and thus taking this game so that's a
big win
for morgan stanley they'll be thrilled
they've been playing really well
throughout the group stage
and well that's just easy at this point
so we'll get out of this one
morgan stanley taking it uh let's go to
another matchup within this
one here chelsea monica this game still
very sharp despite the queens being off
and now we have opposite colored bishops
with d4
anybody oh there it is
there it is that's another tactical
woman wow i mean robert you're just
finding the games at their prime i'm
just you know
i see it we have to move on i just pick
a game and it turns out that there was a
tactical moment there the rook on h1 was
under attack d4 opened that bishop up
and it's still not easy to win this
actually i could see white winning this
game
if you get your pawn to d4 and play pawn
to b5 you get a breakthrough on the
queen side
and the rook for the bishop dynamic that
doesn't mean as much
if there's a past pawn heading your way
and this king is coming up to c4
and i actually think i prefer white's
chances at this point
i think that just like you're saying
white has a lot of practical chances and
especially with one minute versus 20
seconds i think that black could feel
very pressured
i know a lot of times when i play and
you know my
i am an exchange shop two rigs on my
opponent has a bishop i mean
that bishop can become so strong and can
sometimes become better than a rook
and i think that we might be seeing that
in this game perhaps
and the nerves and look at chelsea
monica at over a minute to 20 seconds
for black
and that's what happens when you play a
lot of blitz especially online you are
accustomed
to situations like this where you don't
know who's better you're trying to
assess on the fly
and both of you are getting in time
travel but the pawns on d6
this pawn can go to a7 and that bishop
protects a7
and stops the pawn from getting to f2
while protecting d6 is doing it all
and rook f7 behind the pass from this
king can come into c6
white has two past pawns black has one
and yet the eval bars is completely even
i mean that's that's not what the
players are thinking
that's not how they play your sphere
like net feel right now but
bishop is a very nice move to just stop
the f-punk from pushing
now you guys see that black is trying to
to go for these checks perhaps
i don't know if they want to try to get
a repetition but no
what a brave move by the way king to e5
like just moving the king allowing the
past pawn to go
and it still says even somehow they're
playing accurate moves here completely
even position
it looks to me like white should be uh
punching the pawns through first but of
course d7 drops the rook on d3
and now he likes black because the a7
pawn christine the pawn
the pawn was hanging and now king b7
there's rook to f8
so what is happening here what is
happening this looks absolutely insane
white is a full work down but has these
two extremely strong past pawns i think
this could sort of go
anyway i guess there's eight at some
point but i oh okay
it's when rook b1 watch out for v8 so
let's play rook a8 so you can take this
pawn
yeah why have to be very careful to not
drop any pawn because that would change
the whole dynamic of the position
that's right that would actually
probably end in a loss rook take rookie
d7 i think it's only saved rook f7 check
well that was actually pretty clever by
black to allow the rook to be
take on d7 you're going to win the a7
pawn and
rook and h pawns almost never winning oh
don't don't take
me check me oh my gosh
oh my gosh what a trick by ryosuke nanjo
setting up a meeting net oh my gosh
that was so so tricky and that's what he
was setting up a trap
by bringing the king to d5 because he
saw
that she can go rook b8 he saw that he
could sack the rook
and that the king went to e8 rook a7
rook b5 check is a good move
but after king e6 you need to move your
king out of the opposition
black's king takes away the squares rook
takes h5
a fatal error that is checkmate with a
lone broken king
that was i mean this just shows how
quickly a game can turn around they
played so well
in the time pressure with you know a
very difficult position to play with
because
of all the material imbalances but we
can see that the game can completely
turn around in one
move just like this and look at this the
score it's 2-2 that tied the match
that was a critical victory wow we're
gonna go to the other game still going
on here because
uh we see that elena hamiakova with the
white pieces she's winning this game
against marlena
uh chose so it looks like the pawns are
just pushing g6
g7 bishop c4 should do the trick king on
g6
that's not gonna help your cause you
need to push the g pawn through so i
think
should figure this out the second time
around there it goes g7 bishop c4 g7
actually is mate g7h7
at that point but okay this is easily
winning so king f7 getting queens let's
go the other game
uh remaining here that's this is board
four and
let's go to the other game here oh
this is winning we have a rook end game
the king gets out
if a king comes closer you throw in the
check and then you get
your queen yeah famous famous rook end
game
igor yanich for empty solutions
takes that game over afghani kritov and
wow so this
match is oh excuse me that's for spare
bank
uh trade uni took the two and a half
half lead
and so even though yanez wins the game
it's not enough
a two and a half one half victory for
spare bank trade union
oh my gosh and i still can't get over
that checkmate that we just saw with the
rook on the
a final move i cannot get over that one
either and
i think that that probably hurt a lot to
lose in that way that's one of the ways
that hurts most to lose by just losing
you know in one move with a trick like
that but it was very clever
um it was very clever to set up this
type of trick because you know
practically with this little time it was
very easy for that to happen
obviously you just want to get the the
pawn out of there and just you know
say all right you're going to have to
fight for a draw but this is just a draw
but no that was just a check made in one
move there so
wow incredible game so much pressure
right on the clock we were just talking
about chelsea monica she streams she has
a lot of blitz
so i thought she would be the one who
was more accustomed to that situation
maybe she is
but these things happen as we know we
play a ton of blitz you have a good game
things are going your way and suddenly
you missed checkmate one because it came
out of nowhere so
we do have all matches done we couldn't
get every single game under our
attention unfortunately
but we know that the results
as such spare takes down erg that's good
for yon napomneshi and he made that draw
in a tough position that was
kind of a fortunate escape for him and
spare bank trade union beats empty
solutions two and a half one half
we had a tie two to two between morgan
stanley hungary
and uh pt and we in our final match
of the um around here we had gronke bank
beating anawak two and a half one half
led by georg meyer
on board one he scores a victory for
gronkey
as did alina kashlinskaya the free agent
on board two
she helps that team out so grunky moves
on we will have
a blitz match i guess because of the
tiebreaks let me just confirm with the
team
uh what's going on yup let's see if we
get a blitz match there between morgan
stanley and
that would be very very exciting to to
get a blitz match i think
it's always more exciting with the
little or the lower time control and
these games have already been extremely
exciting so i would really look forward
to
getting a blitz match there so we're
gonna see if we are going to be getting
that but
i have to say that even though we were
not able to watch every single game here
i do think that you know we found some
really nice moments and happy that we
were
able to to follow these these very
exciting moments live
like for instance the rick checkmate or
all of the other uh
tactical moments where we joined in so
thank you
i agree and i still can't believe that
uh anwar accepted that draw against jan
napomnishi because
it's clear that the team from spare is
super strong they were the number one
overall rated team on average and
i know it's jana pomshi but anwar's
grand master
very strong player in his own right and
accepting a draw in that position it
felt like it was letting jan off the
hook
absolutely especially when he had such a
great position
so yeah probably
perhaps should have continued the game
but um
i'm sure he had his reasons but but yeah
it seemed to be a very good opportunity
for them and for that team especially
when you're playing
in a team right because every every
result can really make a big change for
everybody
yeah it's certainly the case and we're
getting word that uh there is gonna be
ten minutes before the next round the
players are going to get settled
there is going to be the whole team
playing three minute
plus two second increment blitz so if
you were here just to play some rapid
chess think again
the players are going to have to test
their medal in blitz games against the
other team
and we just remind everybody that while
we're having
great chess we're having a good time
there also is
money being raised for various
initiatives fide doing a great job
raising funds for players with
disabilities
for veterans who you know have played
chess throughout their careers and need
some support and chess and education so
if you're able to
click on the button and the twitch
channel please use the command
for corp donate and you any generosity
is
extremely appreciated if you can so we
are going to go on a brief break
when we return a couple minutes we'll
get set for the blitz tie break four
games go on at once we'll need to catch
our breath
stay tuned everybody we'll be right back
[Music]
and we return in the playoff stage of
the fide online world corporate chess
championship
anna this was an exciting round four
matchups three have been decided
and we're about to have blitz tie breaks
the best type of tie breaks it's going
to be super exciting i'm really looking
forward to this
and yeah here we can here we can see the
format
so we can see that the top team and well
we can see yeah we're already in the
playoff playoffs
well i was going to say and uh are your
vocal chords right you said you're
excited but are your vocal cords excited
for the fast-paced blitz that we're
about to see with three minutes
and two second increment my vocal cords
are super excited i know that yours are
amazing for this robert and mine are
gonna match this
i'm ready for it i believe that every
step of the way and if
the blitz match is tied two to two just
like the
uh rapid match was then we will be sent
to
armageddon and armageddon is something
in chess where one player the
player the white pieces gets five
minutes black gets
four minutes no increment white will
need to win that game
black can draw the game and that would
count as a win
for the player with the black piece so
draw odds to black tie mods to white
it's always exciting to see armageddon
and the teams actually nominate a player
it's very likely that they'll nominate
their top board but it's also possible
that maybe one of the
other boards is a blitz specialist speed
demon
and so you choose that player but that's
only an event that we have a tie
we see the morgan stanley team we have
them behind the scenes here you can see
them now they're getting ready some of
them were stretching
i'm sure there are nerves i'm sure
there's you know they're very proud
of each other just to be in this playoff
and then to tie two to two
but they'll have to get their mouse
ready each player
because sometimes there's no thinking in
blitz dress you just gotta move
you just gotta move i was gonna ask
robert what do you prefer in armageddon
do you prefer playing with the white
pieces or with the black pieces
oh gosh i would say at it's kind of 50
50 in many regards
i would prefer to have the black pieces
but it also depends on
like what happened before that if i
let's say you're playing a classical
term and then your the
end is some kind of tiebreaker but if
you want a bunch of games i want the
white pieces i'm going to go for that
win
or say ah i drew the last couple games
just down the stretch
let's just hold and make the draw i
would and if i'm playing someone higher
rated
i also would probably want the black
pieces because you know beating them is
very difficult so trying to make that
draw
it's a hard choice to make what would
you choose
a part of me agrees but then there's
another part of me that just
always likes to go for the win and you
know i really
like playing with the white pieces i
feel like my openings are a lot better
with the white pieces so
same time i don't know i think i would
prefer to play with the white pieces and
try to go for a win but it really
depends on the opponent just like you
said
and well we do have liftoff not quite an
armageddon yet starting with a three
minute plus two second increment blitz
c3 played by international master ali
trying to get d4 in
and that's why bishop g4 is often played
let me take your knight at some point
and soften the d4 square but i think
white can just push this pawn that
doesn't stop it and
h3 played first offering the exchange so
anna a
quieter opening to start with in this
game but i like white's position
yeah i play stuff that is similar to
this
uh with black um so i i kind of like the
ideas for black as well
but this is white white does have quite
an active position
and just like you said the idea is for
white at some point to try to take as
much center as possible by going
d4 which is why black wanted to go
bishop g4 to to
to stop d4 immediately and now that's
why also they've going bishop h5
instead of trading because they want to
keep that pin there to avoid d4 being
played
and i like that white has not played d4
yet instead of castling if you play d4
there could be a quick strike for black
in the center
thanks to this pin so i'm agreeing with
you here a6 played
you can take that knight double the
pawns and that was played at some point
you can go queen a4 this is a known idea
to break the pin by getting aggressive
and i think queen a4
could be a very useful move of course
you can just develop your pieces
and white has a lead in development but
if black gets out the bishop pair
should be good let's move on to another
game because i just see the chord in my
eye
this one pawns are storming that was
more of a positional battle to start
with this says
positional chest come on this is trying
to get g6 trying to get h6
but black hasn't castled so it's
possible that farida for monsieur says
okay you're trying to attack me there
my king's running the other direction
that's the thing when white goes for an
attack this early
when black hasn't decided where to
castle okay now black actually made a
choice
by going rook c8 because now they've
decided they're not gonna castle
queen side which is a what would lead to
perhaps a more
positional position because it wouldn't
be this race if you know
uh of black which is what's gonna what's
um yeah which is what we're perhaps
going to be
seeing now but um king b1 was played and
i don't know if the king is gonna stay
in the center on e8 or if they're gonna
go ahead and castle i think they have to
castle at some point but
then these pawns are gonna become very
strong on g5 and h5
yeah super scary to castle but if you do
castle and g6 is played
black can shut it down with h6 so
whichever pawn pushes for white if you
play h6
black will play g6 if you play g6 black
will play h6 kind of deal so
that allows black to castle but it won't
feel truly safe
until you trade the queens off the board
for example because that king with those
pawns storming
could be dangerous exactly and black's
pond
can't really push yet because they sort
of need to see what white does with
their pawns so
they're going to have to stay in this
initial position
and okay now they're deciding to castle
okay
castle what it happened so i mean taking
on f5 makes sense and
maybe some kind of knight f4 knight g3
first so take
the pawn oh h6 is coming okay wow what a
decision to play f6 because
just a move ago if you played like b6
random move h6 you can no longer play g6
and shut it down
because there would be a checkmate so
that's why black f6
himself saying you're not getting in
with your queen
and now after g6 and h6 we can see that
there's been a sort of
lock on the king side attack there so
rookie one was played to to put some
pressure on e6 and now rick c6 also too
to
help out on on uh defending e6 so
if it's like there's not gonna be as
much attack on the
black king anymore and another trying to
double up rooks on the e file
yeah it's all about this pawn now
because black has to sit and defend this
pawn
white's rooks are active and the rook on
e2 just like the rook on c6
defends and attacks there could be some
kind of g4 g5 if black isn't careful you
give up a pawn to break open the
position
because in the event of the pawn going
to g5 which is not happening but if the
pawn went to g5
and black 2 with the h pawn you play h6
to break open
the king side but i like this move queen
g4 you're just forcing black in a sense
to play a move like rookie 8 and sit
defending while white's pieces are
perfectly placed attacking so i like the
position
for peter lizack let's go to another
game just to see what's happening uh wow
okay
this position i see a knight on g5 a
rook on g1 ryosuke nanjo
the hero the japanese international
master saved the day
for morgan stanley and then wait there's
an attack on the
queen side for black a potential attack
in the center for white there's a king
here
who's attacks coming first anna
that's that's a great question i kind of
feel like black's attack is going to be
a little bit faster because that a4 pawn
is hanging now
so it feels like black's pieces are
really going to be
um are really going to be getting into
attack for instance if rick takes a4 now
there's gonna be some rookie one
threat immediately so um i feel like
black is a little bit faster but now
now the e file is getting open and white
has a great rig on e1
so it feels like now white is worth
solidifying
uh their whole position yeah with this
b3 move that's a
pawn chain now going after the defense
actually this has been very good play
from both sides
maybe some of the moves catching us off
guard but i think high quality
and bishop d2 what a move just to go
after the b4 pawn
and the queen can also slide up to f4 or
somewhere else to uh
the f7 pawn was under attack so bishop
d5 attacks
it defends as a great bishop i think i
like
white's chances because this king is on
d8 that doesn't look very safe
white's king actually looks quite safe
for the time being yeah
for now definitely the only thing that
could perhaps be problematic are those
dark squares
in front of the white king but i think
that white would be able to
would probably be able to offend that
and there's not really any clear way for
black to take advantage of that yet
i'm looking at rook takes a4 at some
point because then the queen gets in
here
their checkmating ideas down on the a2
and a1 squares
but this king is in the center and if
your attack doesn't work out you're just
lost right you're sacrificing a rook for
a couple pawns
so rook a6 played i think that's a there
might be a knight c5
queen b8 check that's that actually wins
a pawn that went to pawn oh did not see
that but that's
maybe not the easiest thing to spot
right there but it
doesn't work the second time but knight
takes e5 was available i'll show that
very quickly
the point everyone is after takes takes
queen v8 the queen has to block you
trade queens
at the end of the line the rook takes
the bishop you net upon and black's king
is still in trouble so that was missed
hard to see with no time in the clock
let's uh
just check the other game that we
haven't looked at it's a little bit more
locked up
and we see that white infiltrating with
the queen on d6 just like that other
game the e6 pawn
petra pop in trouble here she's to go to
a passive
defense with knight to g7 white's
position looks amazing
i definitely agree this is sort of the
dream position you want to have when
you're playing
against an isolated pawn and isolated
backwards found that we can
as that's the one on e6 and now you know
they're even bringing this knight to f4
probably to add some extra pressure on
the e6 pawn so every single
piece of white is going to be attacking
that e6 pawn that's just a dream but we
can see now that
black played queen f6 you put some
pressure on this d4 pawn so the knight
cannot move yet
so we can see that black is trying
trying to get some play there as well
that's right g5 trying to open things up
that knight can get to f4 g3 is under
attack
the rook's hanging don't bond the rook
where that move was not
approved of so may is an e5 and d4 kind
of
there it is step one but didn't like
that move so i was looking the same
thing
so i can't blame uh petropap but this
this
eval bar this is blitz for you you don't
have enough time to calculate everything
things are happening before you wait f4
again oh wow
oh that was a fork and now white wins
material another queen
queen oh gosh that's a free queen and
that's a free queen
and we saw her she couldn't believe it
and she's distraught
okay let's uh go back to the games here
she is uh pretty unhappy that was
a big wait queen wasn't taken but she's
down two rooks for night so let's go on
to a new game
let's go to this one here between lavon
bergadzi and mohammed
uh lofty al excuse me this is an end
game where it's
anyone's position because that pawn d3
looks really strong you need your rook
to attack the king
and then this a pawn could start rolling
if you're not careful so
wow what is who's better even material
but
it feels like at first glance black
should be better yeah
that pawn on d3 is real advanced yeah
yeah the pawn
on d3 is super advanced so it feels like
black should be better but
um i mean the pawn on d3 could also
become a target if black is not really
careful
so and if the bishop moves watch out for
a4 a5 a6 i mean that punk can run
yep that pawn can run definitely and you
know that e6 pawn is also quite weak so
i think that as long as as long as that
d3 pawn doesn't get
doesn't get to promote basically this is
totally fine for white and i think that
you should be able to defend that but
rick says have three now there's there's
a pawn hanging there as well
it's true but that pawn can run in a
fight it's one to one by the way we saw
the match even up we have another game
going
it is a rook end game and king c6 can
win this pawn but even if you win that
pun you should not win this game with
the black pieces
because these are double pawns to win
end games you need past pawns
double pawns do not help you create past
pawns but you have to be careful not to
allow this black king in
because uh oh that can't get coming to
e3 if you're not careful give me
three and that could be some checkmate
you have to pincy one you have to go qc1
you just checkmated in this manner the
king can hide
on b2 well what if you take king takes
take on b4 you have rook c4 check so you
do survive
barely barely surviving oh don't allow
king c3 that's you cannot allow this
should be a draw with proper play but
not easy in the end game
we're going to go quickly back to the
other game we got to go back and forth
white took a pawn and that pawn's going
to a7 this is anyone's match
it looks like here for pt they have the
advantage now
but at any moment rugby two check could
happen d2 could happen and then
it could be black winning this game so
oh my god
anything could happen here it's uh hold
on a queen
oh no oh my gosh stepped in line
that's that's what we're saying anything
can happen
and that's going to be a win for pt with
the white pieces up a queen and
checkmate on the board with the bishop
and let's go to the other game because
now pt has a 2-1 lead
and they need a win does morgan stanley
hungry this pawn is on b7 that gives
them a fighting chance
ryusuke nanjo was the player who won
that game one
with rook against rook essentially and
unfortunately rook b2 happens
i don't know if chelsea monica has seen
the results of her teammates you're in
the middle of your own
bullet time scramble but she's doing the
trick here
king here just go i would go rook see a
check please take the pawn
but look at this yeah she has to try it
now she makes the draw do you make the
draw
and morgan stanley hungary is eliminated
they clawed their way back just to get
to the blitz tie break
and unfortunately we'll go back to that
position really oh no we won't
we're oh yes we will sorry to my
producer for making
his life as difficult as possible we
have to go back to this moment here
because
black steals a pawn in the center and
that's like well
you're you're doing great like you're up
a pawn now your pawns on d3
but somehow this pawn went from a3 to a7
before you know it
and the bishop is covering the a8 square
and just
a move king d5 that looks so natural you
only have
one other king move and you tend to want
to avoid the
color that your opponent's bishop is on
right when we're facing opposite colored
bishops
we want to stay on our own bishop's
color unfortunately in this case
that allowed the pawn to promote because
that bishop needed the full line of
sight to the a8 square enna we've all
lost
blitz games like this i mean what can
you say for morgan stanley hungary
to go down in this way when you were
just
on the cusp of going to an army game
keeping this match tied
yeah it really does hurt and we've seen
in this whole match we've seen a lot of
these type of little
tactics that have won the game like for
instance you know here king d5
a8 that's the queen or in the other
match where there was this
or there was this checkmate with the
rook and so there have been a lot of
a lot of you know one move tricks in
this match but that's just part of chess
and especially in faster time control
such as rapid
and even more so in blitz this is this
is basically what happens
and it it hurts to to lose in this way
but
um i think that i think that they've
been playing great
so we have seen really amazing matches i
think they should be happy with their
matches
and yeah
it's just uh at some points you know
being happy is not enough because this
is a competition you want to win
that's the problem you know it's
unfortunate
but what a fight what a fight so let's
uh look at the
updated brackets because we now know our
final four we have spare that's the
yonder palm shield team on the top
uh left of the bracket taking on spare
bank trade union led by anton korbuff so
we're about to have a super grand master
battle
on board one between those teams and
gronka bank taking on pt i think that
gronkin bank is the big favorite
in my opinion led by georg meyer on
board one the
extremely strong super solid grand
master
who also is an amazing blitz player so
if that
match is tied to two and they get to
blitz i think
george can help spearhead that lineup
and i really believe that with
a balanced lineup the rest of the way i
think it's even matchups on boards
uh two through four actually maybe
gronky even has a rating advantage on
board too
i think that that advantage the gm i am
matchup on one leads gronkit to have
the edge over pt but anything can happen
and anna we just saw pt
win this blitz tie break so maybe
they're feeling
more motivated than ever yep that's what
happens if you win a game or chat of
chess or if you win
a match you're gonna feel more motivated
you're gonna have more confidence and
that is
typically going to be shown in your
chess games a lot of times we can see
that those type of players are a little
bit more aggressive or play a little bit
faster
and that can really uh that can really
help out practically
in the game so they they could have an
edge because of the fact that they won
this match definitely
that's right and gronkey is one of the
biggest
supporters in the chess world they have
the grand cay classic and the ground can
open
they have the bodenboden chess club and
the bundesliga and
you know their the chess world will be a
lot worse without the support from
grandkid
and for those of you who are here who
have been a part of this if you can
please do
donate to the initiatives that fide has
put forth
it's for players with disabilities for
veterans and also for chess and
education so do get involved
please hit the panel in the twitch
stream use the
command corp donate if you're able to it
would be greatly appreciated but for now
and i we need to take a break because
that was exciting
i feel white's just seeing the finish
there
we'll be back the rounds will begin at
about approximately half past the hour
so we'll take a brief break and we'll
return we'll get ourselves ready
for the semi-finals
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the feed a
world
corporate championship finals grand
master robert hess alongside me anna
kremling anna
we needed that break because we saw a
blitz
tie break between morgan stanley hungary
and pt
how are you feeling you recovered i have
recovered it took a while because uh it
was a pretty crazy thai break but
i'm recovering now and i'm ready for the
semi-finals
we will have the semi-finals ahead we
have a couple minutes until then we just
wanted to go over
one moment from a game that happened in
the blitz match
and it was between peter lizack
representing morgan stanley hungary
and fareed for manzi from pt so the
player with the black pieces moves on
with the team
but in this position it looks pretty
difficult for black because
white is having all the fun here there's
rook staring down at the e6
pawn the g6 pawn keeps that king on the
back rank but anna we see the engines
say zero
so from experience what can you say in
positions like this where the engine
tells you just shuffle your pieces
around
how difficult is that to do i think it's
very difficult to do i think that
as a as a chess player you don't just
want to make random moves you want to
have a plan behind every move so
to just be shuffling your pieces around
it's something that's not very
intuitively
you want to you want to come up with
plans and and and you want to do stuff
so it's very difficult
that's right and i look at the engines
it's zeros i look at the position
zeros this looks like a fun game to play
especially in blitz
and let's see how this went because at
this moment black one a5 you see
the evaluation starts to creep up in
white's favor and there as he gets more
depth it sees
white's advantage growing a bit and the
reason why a5 is played is to go b4 and
for an attack
the reason why that could backfire is
now the b5 pawn needs to have an eye
kept on it
white with queen b3 black one rook c4
okay defending the pawn
queen went to d3 and then b4 was played
and white said
i'll just push through and now i'll play
b3
my queen will come into a square like a6
or b5
and black's problems still exist so it
still says even
but the position is becoming
increasingly difficult for black to play
because when you push pawns forward
you leave space behind and you don't
control the squares they once controlled
so
black one b3 all in for the attack
trying to
double rooks and that's the sign of a
player who does not like their position
they think i'm going to lose this game
if i do nothing
and anna check this out rook takes e6
step one
rook b8 okay defending rookie two good
move
and look at this move
that's a that's a winner queen a7 that's
a beautiful way to win a game
very pretty that king has this
background
problem so if the queen takes the queen
well then there's going to be
rookie checkmate um because the
the pawn on g6 is so strong it's taking
away those escape squares f7 and h7
so the king cannot escape and that was a
very beautiful tactic and i think that
was really cool with this game is
what you mentioned before that may
perhaps if they just shuffle the pieces
around it's equal but
i thought that black's plan of pushing
the pawns in front of the king made a
lot of sense
i think it's something that a lot of
players would do because you know you
have to come up with some sort of plan
and
pushing the pawns and creating an attack
for the king makes a lot of sense so
i think it's really cool to see how that
could backfire that's right and even if
we go back to this move 21
and as soon as you see this pawn here
you forever have to worry about your
back rank so the position
became increasingly challenging for the
black side
because that king can never quite get
out so a queen trade would help you
but until those queens come off your
king's not running into the center of
the board and that's why i think white
maintained the pressure and ended up
winning the game unfortunately for peter
lizac the team did not move on
but it was an instructive moment
nonetheless and okay we are getting set
for the semi-finals i am excited for it
so we have just two matches in this
round
four games all four players on the team
play
only in one game so yonder palm she
will be taking on anton korabov in a
matchup of the world's elite blitz
players
and rapid players superstars but anna if
you're the rest of the team right you
look at board one like i don't know
what's gonna happen there they can
beat each other how do you manage your
own games while out of the corner your
eye
looking at your teammates it's very
difficult i think it's something that
you have to kind of balance it you sort
of want to know how the team is doing to
you know
sort of understand what what result your
game
needs to finish in because obviously if
all of your teammates have won maybe you
know there's just
you just need to make a draw for your
team to win which is the most important
thing but at the same time
if you're constantly focusing on every
any everybody else's game then you're
gonna stop focusing on yours so
i think that most players what they
typically do is that they just focus on
their own game and they
kind of take it as it comes and then you
know if they if they perhaps are offered
a draw or something they'll see how the
team has done but i think mostly they
will be focusing
on their own games right and
it's difficult because you add the
periphery you're looking and looks like
games are starting so let's actually
pull
this up here we have yonder palms the
white pieces against anton corbin and we
have a french so
i am somebody who does not like the
french defense very much because the
bishop on c8 gets caught here but anna
maybe you have different feelings about
this opening
i don't play the french i don't even
play e4 as white so
i don't really see the french in a lot
of my own games
but i think that i sort of feel the same
way that bishop on c8 does become really
bad and
it becomes a bit difficult to play in
that regard but it's just preference
some people
really like to play it that's right and
the bishop on c doesn't get out it's
stuck behind the wall of pawns and
pieces
but though black plays it because often
the underlying
structure is extremely solid you have
this pawn chain from f7 to d5
that makes your bishop worse but your
pawns feel safe and this is still
theoretical so i think we can come back
here in a bit
uh they will this theoretical discussion
will continue
they'll figure it out let's go on to
georg meyer in the grunky match
against pt because i was saying that
this was the biggest advantage
for gronke the grand master against
international master and
york meyer very strong grandmaster at
that but with the white pieces
anna do you just play solid chess and
try to make a draw or do you say i don't
care about your rating it's an
individual game
let's just play chess i am more of the
second type
i like to just play out the games i
always want to play my best and
even if george meyer is a very high rate
player obviously a draw at four
for for white here would be a good
result i think that you know you should
just try to play
to play out the game and see how it
comes but
i think that that's also what he's going
to try to do we'll see and
york is thinking so that indicates to me
he's considering the capture on f6 with
the pawn
otherwise you just take with the queen
right away and if you take with the pawn
that can give you some attacking chances
but it also gives you double pawns which
may not be the best situation so georg
very experienced in the french he is the
maybe the
leading expert in the french in the
world he is always playing at his tried
and true opening
and anna what do you think which way is
going to take on f6
i think that gtx f6 is very interesting
because of that idea of of opening up
the g-file
and um i mean i'm not really used to
these positions but i think that that
really does look very interesting so
perhaps he's gonna
actually take with the with the g pawn
perhaps thinking with the queen is a
little bit more solid but
i think it can lead to some very
interesting positions i actually think
that
sorry to interrupt you there i think
being solid can backfire in a position
like this
and that's why he does take with the
pawn the great decision because this
bishop
dominates the bishop on c8 this pawn b7
is under attack
so his main purpose in doing this is to
try to play this f5 move
it's it's weird right we this this is
more solid like how could this be better
it's because if you try to take the
solid approach after
say a take on d4 i probably can take
with the queen on d4 but i also can say
let's stop one move short there could be
a queen b5 check bishop takes b7
this king's in the center and a move
like that staring in both direction
black is underdeveloped and white is
fully developed with all the pieces
flying
yeah i definitely think that just like
you said playing solid can backfire
and i think that's one thing a lot of
times when somebody's trying to play for
a draw
the problem with playing for a draw is
the fact that when you're just playing
trying to just play solid and play for a
draw
you typically play quite passive and you
you can give your opponent a lot of
chances
so that's why it's so important to
always play actively even if you want to
draw in a game
that's right and i think that now
speaking of actively f5
for black bishop can come to g7 and
that's
in part why york takes with the pawn on
f6 he can fianchetto this bishop
long diagonal to work with and the king
can't steal castle king side it's not
unsafe over there so let's keep
in this match let's go to alina
kashlinskaya on board too she's the free
agent
this is a locked up position where white
has the bishop pair
but this is your quote-unquote extra
bishop for one of these knights
that bishop can't find daylight at least
not for the time being
because look at black structure very
typical way to say
hey that's not a disadvantage to have
the knights yeah
we can see this big big big big big
block of pawns here in the
center which is blocking the bishop but
now perhaps the bishop is going to get a
little bit more
of light perhaps because now after d
takes e4
well it's it's giving a few more squares
for the bishop but we can definitely see
that this bishop on g2 is not an amazing
piece
that's right is a good piece and it can
go to b3 attacks the pawn text the queen
so i think that uh international master
for monsieur said all right i don't want
to open that bishop as you were just
highlighting
but maybe tactically it will work out
for me and as you see on the evaluation
bar it says it's a completely even
position
yeah this is another one of those though
that i think that the
evil bar says that it's a it's an equal
position but there's just so much play
here
uh there's this is gonna be a long game
and you know nothing is decided here
i don't let's keep on in this match
we'll go to
the next one with board three hana marie
kleck is board three for gronka bank
we have masuri raman board three for pt
and
what is going on with these pawns here
for why these pawns here
it's white's turn anna help me out which
pawn do we take do we have to take can
we leave it
i'm confused i am very confused as well
that's the thing when you have all of
these pawns
in the center and all of these traits
you just gotta think about you know
which pun is the one that we should take
um i
think well right now uh i think that i
kind of like taking on d5 because it's
it's upon that it's a little bit less
protected
and um i don't know if after knight
takes there could be like perhaps i
don't know like
okay yeah c4 perhaps it's not good
because knight before but okay it's
taking on e5
um having the same show that we are i
asked you the question because i
genuinely didn't know what to do
and uh he says i'm gonna take on e5
rather than anything else and
it seems like with the series of trades
black's position looks pretty nice to me
you're already castled and
i don't know i think that there's no
opening disadvantage whatsoever
yep i totally agree now white castle
because they had to castle
as quickly as possible especially
all the center getting open very soon so
it made a lot of sense at the castle
robert i have to ask you you know you
were you we were talking about the
french before
and i saw somebody say that you drew
anon with a french at some point is that
true
we don't talk about success in the
french defense
it is true i i i did have uh you know
one good game in the french
so uh you know we'll leave it at that
but uh here
this position i think a huge opening
success for hannah marie kleck
and that's good news for grunke and
let's go to board 4 in grand cay because
that is inna
agrest where is her game there it is
against
chelsea monaco so two very strong
players these ratings
that's not their real raise they're like
2 300 each
not 2100 but even the 2100 level is very
strong
so this position is very closed but
white can play for b4 at some point
trying to pry open the queen side and if
you go
rook to b1 that could help you go after
this b5 pawn so i would say
anna the biggest problem for black bad
bishop bad bishop
and white's pieces get a little more
activity
and you can play the king sides of boot
yeah
no i totally agree um it's fun to see a
swedish player here that ina is playing
it's really fun to see that
but um i definitely think that in this
position our pieces are more active
and b4 immediately just seems like a
very strong move
because of this pin once again with with
the queen
um so i think that b4 immediately just
seems like a very active move and very
strong
and that pawn on b5 could be under some
pressure
after after an exchange but we can see
that she went for knight h4
she's she wants to place a knight on f5
i think it was kasparov who said that a
knight on f5
is worth a pawn so knight and f5 are
always
really good so it makes sense that she
wants to transfer that knight there
and she's realizing the tactics work in
her favor because when i see knight h4
and the bishop one e7 i think
wait a second my knight moves out the
way that knight can be captured in h4
but if i take either on d5 or e4 it
actually doesn't really matter
because uh there are several ways to win
this one is to go knight f5
and take this bishop with check when you
take the bishop on e3
you could also just play pawn takes a
knight and after bishop h4
my queen comes to h5 with a checkmate
threat and the bishop under attack so
you would actually
lose the piste here for black not
recommended
and rook once it takes takes
one rook pair of rooks to come off this
knight coming to f5
g6 can be played but then after g6 maybe
that bishop gets into h6 so it said rook
a8
and i think you should even trade these
rooks plant this pony on f5
and say i'm going to press forward yeah
i think that the issue here is the fact
that black pieces
are pretty uncoordinated but also very
passive
this we can see this bishop on a8 is not
doing anything
and this bishop on f8 is is trying to
defend a bit on the king side and
i think that white's pieces are just
going to start to such attack and become
very active and i think it's going to be
hard for black to defend
i agree and the one thing you should be
careful is a file the only open file so
if black can quickly bring this queen
down somewhere to attack the pawns that
could be a problem but
white's there first and this b5 pawn's
in trouble because
you can't play c4 your pawn is pinned if
you play b4
and she doesn't but b for that c4 square
would have been white's for the taking
and that's a great spot for the knight
so queen a5 played
attacking the c3 pawn ultimately i think
that's a pretty decent choice but bishop
takes b5
can still be played and i like white's
pieces
and maybe there's even after queen c3
and i did like bishop c6
trying to encourage the trade get a past
pawn
yeah black needs to try to find some
type of counter attack and obviously
white still needs to be careful but
it seems as if white does have the the
better position here and the better
chances for this game
certainly and let's go to the other
match we have jan napomischi take on
anton korbov we saw this early on in the
french
now we're in a queenless position where
there's an
isolated pawn on d5 that's not good news
for korreboven
know what else is not good news anna
look at the clock situation
very bad news the clock situation what
four extra minutes for
a nepo and what do you think can korvov
hold off he is a
superstar he's a super grand master does
he have chances to hold this
even though it looks bad in the initial
position i mean chances to hold this i
definitely think he has but he's going
to probably suffer in this
end game because white's plan is always
going to be to put as much pressure as
possible
on d5 by you know perhaps going rook d1
perhaps even doubling works on d1
and also you can see that white even has
the the c file open right now so even
white's pieces are more active
than black's pieces in this position so
i definitely think that he's going to
have a
tough time but holding it i
think that there are chances that he can
hold this yeah i agree
it's a position where most players they
look at when you talk about holding this
is okay for black but i'm looking at yon
na pamashi he is
one of the world's best players he's in
the co-lead at the candidate tournament
which determines who plays magnus
carlson
for the world chess championship so i
like white's position as you said
let's go after this pawn on d5 and if
the pawn moves maybe that helps
my knight get into this d6 square using
this pawn e5 i think white has a very
nice position
let's go to the second board here in
this matchup
and here we go alexander kadetsky
with the black pieces against evgeny
kretov
what's going on opposite-colored bishops
doubled pawns here
and the last one played was a5 i think
we understand that this bishop
wants to do some work on the diagonal
it does it wants to find nice square and
that b4 square is a nice square there's
no pawn that can attack it
ever so it's going to be able to stay
there there's also
no other minor piece that could be
exchanged for that
before bishop so it's going to be a very
strong bishop now because that white is
going for the queen exchange here
i was about to say the queen exchange
indicates to me that white is probably
i'm not really planning to win this game
i would love to win the game
but if black takes this c pawn can't go
the bishop and the rook
team up on a dark square and perhaps
that c pawn becomes a weakness rather
than the strength
the bishop can of course wrap around the
b5 square all is protected
i think the most likely result by far is
a draw because neither side will really
be able to make too much progress
yeah i thought it i totally agree um i
think that
it's gonna be just like you said very
hard to make any progress
it's it looks like a decent position for
both of them but it's difficult to know
how exactly they are gonna be able to
continue the game now get away
that's right so let's keep on in this
match board three maxime lavrov taking
on fyodor
michikov and okay i see this knight on
d5 i like that but i also see it's under
attack
and the material count black is down a
pawn
but has the bishop pair and in
particular the bishop on c5 looks pretty
nice for black
so if the material stays the way it is
white can claim an edge
and push for more but there's that
active counter play for black at least
some pressure going forwards and uh i
would prefer white's position but how
big of an advantage would you say white
has here
i would say that white um
well they are a pawn up but just like
you said black has
like hassan attack has this nice bishop
on c5
um wow they're going for h5 now so i
think that this is just a type of
position where
white just has to defend from any
immediate any immediate threats like for
instance here h4 is an
is an immediate threat i guess um
perhaps
so i think that that's more what they
have to do but i think that in the long
term it's going to be
fine for white i can't really see black
winning immediately here so so i think
that i think that white is doing pretty
well and i think there's also a lot of
resources for white to defend like
this and i can go to f4 now and all the
pieces are sort of
together around the king so i think that
white is doing pretty well here
i i'm with you and i'm looking at the
clock situation an extra minute
still three minutes for black that's
plenty of time for experienced players
but that extra time could come in handy
with the extra pawn so
h5 is a great move as alpha zero type of
let's go h4
you can't take the pawn on h5 because
your knight needs that bishop's defense
so h4 is the plan to soften up the g3
square or plant upon h3 for an attack
i think that black with that move i'm
starting to like the chances more i
still prefer white's position
let's keep on in this match the last
board we have maria
comey gina with the black pieces and i
see the eval bar
in black's favor and it's because these
pawns here
are fantastic for black it's even
material white has this connect four
pawn chain
but the pawns in the center are mobile
whereas white's pawns are stopped
none of them can move on the dark
squares
yep none of them can can move and
it's just this just looks very very this
just looks very well
to be honest uh these two pawns are
going to be absolutely amazing the f and
e pawn especially in an end game i think
that e pawn is going to be
super strong and now they just took on
on h5
it just seems like they're up material
right one two three four five six
two three four yeah she's up one pawn so
this just seems
just seems very good it was an
understandable mistake h5 was played
because you want to win the f5 punch i
don't want my h-phone i want this f5
pawn because then e4 is weak
but unfortunately h5 comes with the cost
of this rook black takes that very
quickly
i will say that black's position while
you're ahead of material
it could come under fire if you're not
careful if you
allow this capture on e4 there could be
some attack but for
starters you have to deal with the
bishop first this knight can just sit on
g5
so black is well ahead and if you play
carefully
you should be able to take this point
yeah that knight on g5
is going to be a very strong night and
it's just going to protect the whole
king
and white cannot even go knight f3 to
try to exchange it
uh because of this pawn on e4 so that
knight on g5 is just a monster
it is indeed and this would be a very
good
game for spare to take over spare bank
trade union uh
at first i was going to say spare but
then i realized they're kind of playing
each other
so i can't just say that and this game
looks very good for black let's keep on
going
uh throughout these games i'm just going
to pull one at random at this point
let's go to alina kashlinsky's game
where with the white pieces she is down
upon and
her king is under attack so fareed for
monsieur with the black pieces we saw
the karakan the bishop
now has a diagonal to work with but all
the other pieces are gone and blacks up
a pawn with an attack
yeah this is looking really really
really great
um for fi manchia i mean alina is
completely
restricted in the sense that her queen
cannot really move anywhere the queen is
going to have to stay on the first rank
to prevent the queen black's queen from
going to g1 and checkmate so
this just because of that fact just
looks absolutely amazing for
um or for mancha but also the fact that
you know she she is even a pawn up there
yeah wow queen g5 played protecting the
pawn on g3
and if h6 where's this okay the bishop's
under attacks
look at this grand masters do blunder h6
blunders the piece i'm trying to
distract the queen from g3
but i can't forgive my bishop so f6 that
would potentially weaken the king if the
queen can come to f3 and get some checks
in
so you have to be very precise at a
moment like this you don't want to
blunder
like i just did and one idea is queen e1
to make sure the
white's queen can't get back on the
first ranks then you can play bishop to
d4
i feel like black should be able to get
through it by the way
yon napominshi have to go to that game
has won
his individual matchup against anton
korboff
the final position was one where he got
that rook into c7
he pushed that pawn to e6 that's bad
news for the king on f8
yeah now that just looks super strong we
were talking about it before if corbett
was going to be able to defend
um his position but it seemed like it
was not due to the
past pawn or the isolated pawn that
corbett lost but it was
due to how great nippo had all of his
pieces and the very weak king
that that korboff had and also you know
that pin there so
it seemed as if it was not just due to
isolated pawn
that's right and i'm going to go to this
game here in
the other match because i'm looking at
this end game and now
in august we loved her position earlier
but chelsea monica has found a way out
of this
it looks like it's going to be an even
trade this pawn cannot be defended
unless you put your knight on d6
and white will not take that knight at
least not yet the king will come to g3
it should be a level position so that's
going to be
presumably of all things hold a draw on
this board i'm going to go to the georg
meyer game
where he's still playing this is the
most york meyer position
that you could possibly have white the
engines is slightly better
york has under a minute left but he's
the bishop pair so
he's going to try to work his magic play
a nice
end game here to try to take down his
opponent but it's 94 such a problem for
black to deal with
yeah definitely bishop a6 okay so he's
trying to
to kick the kick that work away i am
very
impressed i mean there's a big rating
difference in this game and i think that
white is playing really well
and he's also up on time so i think that
you know
um i mean has been playing super well
this game
rexy7 is going back and now we can see
that he's trying to get this repetition
of moves he's trying to get a draw here
bye and maybe we're going to see that
because we can see that they're
repeating at this moment so the game
might finish
right here if i'm york i'm looking very
quickly other games if even if i go down
to five seconds left i need to make sure
my team doesn't need me to win
he's probably keeping out he makes a
draw let's go within this match
and let's go to elena kashlinska that's
their board too
bishop on e4 this is under attack maybe
you can't play f6 you drop the pawn on
g6 that's
not something you want to do but f5
could be a good idea
of the queen e7 check as soon as he
pushes f pawn
your king gets in trouble so you have to
be yeah precise here
you have to be very precise i thought
that before it was quite interesting
because it looked as if
white almost had no moves like black had
their pieces in such a great position
that it almost seemed like white cannot
really move anything it was
almost like a six swank so it's
interesting to see
how how the position changed and how how
they got here
but yeah this this still just looks
absolutely amazing for for mancha
and i guess that she wants to it's it's
different it's difficult when they
already have their
oh in such a great position but queen a1
okay i was not expecting them but i
thought the bishop was going to move
instead
and i would put my queen on e3 and ask
you how you're going to beat me and the
evaluation went from minus 9
to now minus 1.3 but that's why engines
can be so misleading that position
i don't know what black's best move is
here like this looks like a tough
position because
the queen defends the queen attacks you
can't play f5 because of the checks
and queening one looks like a reasonable
move but after queen e3 and queenie two
the king feels safer
now play queen g2 queen f3 try to trade
the queens off the board if those queens
come off
white is not losing this game or i guess
bishop g2 is just hey my king is tucked
on h3 and safe so
somehow alina kashinska she is saving
this one
at least for now let's go to some of the
other games
where we see okay we were looking
earlier where black was totally winning
and black still has a big advantage but
i'm looking at this d-pawn
as a potential problem for black
especially as we approach time trouble
all right we're gonna have to bop around
here oh okay though this king this
king's in trouble that's actually a
great
move the king is in trouble yes king g4
check right there and if the king goes
to h5 you get checkmated immediately so
rook at four king age five you go rook
to e4 and that's game
checkmate you can't stop it that's a
nice puzzle that's
uh yeah very very cool checkmate
yeah she they're they're going yeah
she's going for rook for check here now
so we're gonna see where the king goes
king has to go to g3 and the other she's
just going to keep on checking
and then this king comes into oh well
don't drop the pawn you want to drop the
pawn but at some point soon the king can
go to f6 the pawn can't move
because e6 is hanging i just saw
quartermaine hannah marie cluck
wins the game by resignation she is up
at rook and
you want to know how she's up a rook
rook d8 was just played
and she took so hannah marie kleck gets
that win for gronkey that's huge and
what a slip
because queen f8 looks like white on the
offensive but she played g5 so her king
can escape
oh gosh that's a sad turn of events for
pt and grunky must be thrilled
yup yup we've seen some of those and you
know they really hurt
those type of those type of blunders but
they happen
and especially with little time so let's
go back to the game with helena
yeah did you see that it was like -17
and king h6 was the wrong move which
means that
somehow you probably should play the
queen here and g5 g4 and go for some
checkmate but it's not it's easier said
than done maybe g5 right away is the way
to go
and that's probably it but it's hard to
play with g5 with 30 seconds in your
clock you worry about your
your own king and now it's back to even
so for that
one moment there black hat it again
and eric meyer has made a draw so hannah
marie kleck
wins the game that means it's tie uh two
to one so the worst that gronke
can do is i think
the worst they can do is tie but unless
i'm mistaken
because oh they won wait i'm now very
confused
by this inaugural is still playing so
we'll see how that one finished out but
right now white on this board is doing
okay
all the games are finishing the same
time we have too much to deal with look
at this game between kadatsky and kretov
opposite colored bishops we saw a player
in the previous match
unfortunately slip and allow the pawn to
promote this time
neither player allowing that at least
for now no they're not gonna make the
same mistake again that's a good thing
when you make one mistake
you start thinking uh more about like
really
preventing that from happening again so
i'm sure that they're not gonna allow
any
pawn from promoting here and spare is up
three nothing so
uh it looks like this game no matter who
ends up victorious if anybody it's not
going to make a difference
for the match spare will move on being
spare bank trading
let's go back to the other match because
that of course has much more at stake
oh sorry i clicked on the wrong game i
was going here but black did win that
game we were looking earlier
so fareed for matcha is still trying to
win he needs to win this game
with black and i would even consider
queen f4 check right now i'm not sure
if that end game holds but it's a move
to consider to trade the queens off
because obstacle bishop end games
notorious for being drawn
this is going to become a difficult game
to play though i think for
both players and black is trying to like
is trying to find
that big advantage and finding a way to
convert this to a win
and for white is going to be really
difficult to play because the king is
unsafe but now we can see that
white has found a way to check the black
king and now it seems almost as if for
manchester wants to exchange those query
but
she should take that queen her team is
up two to one if i'm not mistaken
i see that i should definitely take that
queen in agares drew
georg meyer drew and um how do we
collect one
she just needs to draw but she might not
know that because she's in the middle of
a time scramble but she just needs to
draw
trade queens if you can
yeah change queens and it's just
immediately a draw with this
take
she's playing like not for a witness
maybe she thinks this is the easiest way
to hold but trading queens
ensures that she makes a draw and her
team moves on and it looks like we'll
get a repetition
so she gets away with decision not to
trade queens if
the repetition is don't get a repetition
wow
but it seems as if yeah there we go
there was nothing that black could do to
escape so
alina kashlinska she did not win her
game haunted me cluck did win for
gronkey they went two and a half one and
a half
but she might be the hero by if you just
look at the scorecard and say well the
player who won is the hero alina
kashinsky was completely busted
according to the engine
but it was much more difficult than you
know met the eye it's like
to find that wind where is it we were
looking there was no clear way
but there was at that one moment i don't
even know what move it is this game
finished at 92 moves
somewhere around these parts maybe it
was even actually earlier than this
gotta find this moment where the king
was going back up in h3 and h2
i guess g5 that's the move there we have
it
giving up your h5 pawn because g3 is
checkmate the bishop and the queen line
up on the square
if you don't do anything g4 check will
win
and if you trade and say okay i can't
allow g4
that's too scary let me move my king
back a move like h4
should be good but actually g4 is even
stronger
because your queen has to move and your
queen cannot stay in line with the g3
pawn
hard to see this with 30 seconds though
very difficult to see it especially
because
g5 really does change the whole dynamic
of the position
and whenever you move a pawn in pretty
much any position it really does change
how how it really does change the whole
position the dynamic of it so
it's really hard to see that with 30
seconds even though it was
a very good tactical move and
yeah i mean i'm sure that i'm sure that
perhaps you'll be a bit upset if not
finding it but that's just that's just
how it is sometimes it's little time
yeah and you know he he had a good game
he was playing well with the black
pieces and queen b7
check right that's why you don't play
move like g5 you don't want this kid to
get checked too much but that's only one
check
and the king can escape on a dark square
and that's the end of your checks
and on the other side i'm going to check
and go for a checkmate so yeah
very difficult to analyze this though
with the little time and to realize that
there's no checks left in that position
but
yes because the fear is if you make this
pawn push immediately becomes a draw
and on the other hand by the moves that
he was playing with the black pieces he
was trying to keep
the momentum saying okay i'm going to
keep this position the status quo is
good enough for me because i will be
able to make
progress later whereas if i allow an
immediate perpetual check
or some kind of queen trade then i have
no chances but ultimately
it was a missed opportunity pt does not
win their match it's not on
international master mantra here it's a
team effort
and pt they just barely
made it to the semi-finals unfortunately
they're barely eliminated in
this round so we know our final two
teams
we have our final two teams this game by
the way ended in the draw just for
reminding everyone it was a repetition
our final two we have
gronke bank and spare so
as you look at this we know that georg
meyer tops the line for gronka bank
yon napaneshi for spare so strong
grandmasters
on board one i mean strong as an
understatement but exceptional
grandmasters on board one
and then iams on board two the lowest
board is still
well near 2300 anna
what do we expect i think that anything
can happen here it's going to be such a
close match and it's going to be
so exciting to follow this final i
really cannot wait
um it's going to be super exciting as
well to follow this george meyer
and this versus nipple game it's going
to be really really
really amazing to follow such a high
level chess game
george just drew versus nippo one so
perhaps nipple is feeling a bit more
more confident but once again anything
can happen here and they're both amazing
rapid and blitz players
and if you're yon you just beat anton
korbov one of the
world's top players you're feeling good
like you said and it's reminding
everybody there will be
two games so you you play your first
match then there's a rubber match
oh actually that's not a rubber match
but there's a second match where
it's eight games total so unlike the
previous rounds where we've been
best out of four it's best out of eight
your team needs to score four and a half
points
throughout the two rounds to win the
match so we are going
to take a break but before we do just to
remind everybody if you can please
click that panel do donate if you're
able this event
is to raise awareness to raise money for
charity
and for some great causes and for the
for fide they are trying to do more for
players with disabilities
for some of the elder players for the
veterans
and for chess and education so it's very
important if you can we have received
many
generous donations to this point thank
you so much for this and we will be back
shortly with more coverage of the
fide world corporate chess championship
[Music]
do
welcome back everybody to the feed a
world corporate chess championships this
is
the final we have two teams remaining we
will see action begin
at 10 minutes past the hour we want to
remind everybody
of what the format is now that we have
reached the final it's a bit different
than the
quarters and the semis because the
players will play
two matches you get the white color and
the black color against the same
opponent
and if it is a four to four tie we will
go to a
tie break blitz match three minutes plus
two second increment
anna what if the final determined by
armageddon
that would be for us absolutely amazing
for us commentators and for everybody
else watching that would be absolutely
amazing but for the players
i think that would be very stressful
because
as we said before our regents are
stressful enough by by themselves
but at armageddon in a team it's a lot
more stressful because there's so much
pressure and yeah i think i think that
we would feel better about it than them
that's true we enjoy it it's fun for us
as commentators but as players it's
nerve-wracking and let's remind
everyone what is at stake because it is
a chess competition
glory playing better chess sure
but there are prizes so the winning team
is declared the fide online world
corporate chess champion
i think that much is fairly
straightforward and the first
four teams in the rankings secure forces
each
to participate in a simul against the
winner of the candidates we do not know
who the winner of the kens is that
tournament will resume in april and that
could be
maxine vashi lagrav or jan napomnishi
who's taking part in this they're the
co-leaders
or it could be fabiano caruana nishkiri
etc and
four players from each of the highest
ranked teams who did not qualify for the
playoff stage
will be able to play against juwon june
that's a really exciting experience anna
very very exciting i think that all of
these prizes
are are super exciting especially for
the people in their corporations that
uh perhaps you know haven't had the
opportunity to meet
all of these top elite players it would
be a really cool experience
that's just a lot of players are
thankful just to be taking part
and you know the last part of this is of
course for the charity and that's a big
component of this
there's chess playing everyone in the
event loves chess that's why they're
taking part in this
but you see the team that raised the
most money will be invited to the
world championship match held later in
2021 that will be between magnus carlson
and the aforementioned winner of the
feed a cannons tournament so you have
three nights
vip tickets that will be a fantastic
experience and
there are many players enjoying this
competition not just the players
who are left remaining and we have a
tweet showing appreciation and it is
from
vanessa jetvah whose game we're
analyzing in detail
yesterday because he played a great one
1300 raiden was playing in someone who
was 2100 plus
and actually had a great position over
playing
out playing i should say his opponent
and you see the tweet here best game i
played till date
in my chess career what a moment to see
my game getting featured on an official
live stream of this elite event
can't express how it feels to outplay a
professional title player
with a much higher rate than you thank
you well thank you we're glad you
participated
it's a very nice to see that you enjoyed
your experience
it is the first feed a world corporate
championship held online
i presume it will not be the last let's
hope it's not and we like everyone's
participation and we have just two
minutes
before the round begins i wanted to talk
about this end game
and when you're calculating this late
stage of the game
don't have much time if you're black how
do you determine just
on like a conceptual level whether to
trade rooks and promote your pawn
and calculate the ensuing king and pawn
in game
it's it's a very difficult thing to do
especially like you said with the
with the little time um
i would say that i mean obviously it
depends on
on like the king's position so in this
position the king on
on g1 is is holding this
f1 square so the pawn f2 could could
promote very soon but then at the same
time
you can see that the king that is going
to f7 is going to be able to walk all
the way
to d7 and protect c7 and then that king
is going to
be after after the bishop sacks itself
or
it has to take the pawn and c7 yeah you
can put out the moves
so to make it a bit more clear then you
sort of have to calculate this position
and where the king will be closer to
taking that a pawn
then the black king will be able to
either protect the pawn or
take the a4 pawn so i think that
in this position you sort of have to
calculate if that
king and pawning game is going to be
winning and that is something that
um it's a bit different with an apon
because
um there are all of these style meeting
ideas okay we're gonna get that we're
gonna get the game started
yep too bad we were talking i yo that's
my fault didn't uh
bring it up in time was reading the
tweet but uh the games are beginning we
don't want to miss the action we can
talk about the rest of the end game
later
george meyer starts with the white
pieces against ian napoli
we see knight f3 and c4 an english
opening system
by georg we will have our eyes on all
four games
and it's the first of two matches
everybody so uh
only four boards we know exactly who's
playing gronke
against spare and this is the
heavyweight matchup on board one but
equally
important are some of these other games
so uh it's still
very early on i don't think we need to
hop around just yet
but anna i always like these bishops on
g2 i just
i'm a big fan of the enchanter i'm a big
fan of the fiance as well as long as
there's not a big massive pawns blocking
the bishop in the center but in this
position that's not the case
the bishop on g2 has the full diagonal
and it's a
it's a very active piece so i definitely
prefer that bishop on g2 over the bishop
on d7 well the bishop on d7 could at
some point exchange itself for that
bishop but
that's another story no that's
irrelevant it's definitely relevant
detail
you often want to trade off this
powerful bishop and the bishop came to
d7
to protect the knight on c6 to protect
the knight c6 no you're not going to
take that
but there are moments where you do take
if black is forced to take with the pawn
to shatter the
structure on the queen side but look at
yon i mean f6
you're creating a pawn chain here this
knight can come to e6 potentially
he can castle king side i do like his
bishop
white plays f4 to strike in the center
and you know george's position to my
eyes
is favorable but young playing quickly
and confidently
and uh it's going to be a messy game
it's going to be
an amazing game to follow i'm so excited
about this game and it's really i mean
these are just two
top top players it's going to be such a
high quality chess game
and i'm super excited to see what they
bring to the table
and strong players on all four boards
less excitement if i bring up this game
between
elena kashlinskaya and alexander
kadetsky because
the queens are off the board nothing
major has happened except for the queen
trade
and the move a6 played by elena allowing
this bishop to take the knight
because those double pawns won't be here
for very long once black takes in the
center
so the bishop pair we hear about that
all the time isn't that just a good
thing
for black to have the bishop here yes it
is but even though the pawns will not
remain doubled they could be attacked
and oftentimes white wants to put a
knight on b3 and try to take over these
dark squares on the king side the pond
on a6 and c6 leave squares here
available for white to try
and take advantage of yeah exactly
so well just like i said even though
bishop pairs we hear about them all the
time and they are great
um i mean it also like kind of depends
on the position
and if the bishop pair if the bishops
are going to be good in a certain
position
so i don't know would you say that the
bishop pair
is strong in this position robert for
black i would say white's position
because the lead in development and
that's part of it and this bishop on the
light squares that's the problematic
piece
if this this may be a bit uh hard to
recognize for many
but if black has to trade these pieces
for
these pieces so the bishop and knight
for white the dark square bishop and the
knight for black
this light square bishop is very bad
against the knight because of the dark
square holes
on the queen side so this is what you
need to think about as you grow as chess
players
what pieces do we want traded and how
can i take advantage of some of my
opponent's weaknesses
having a knight against a bishop that
knight can go from color to color and
a knight on a dark square cannot be
attacked by a light square bishop
exactly and those are the advantages and
disadvantages of
of uh of having a bishop player or you
know having knights instead so it all
depends on the
exact position that's right and well
this position still early
players are thinking let's move on to
board four for a second
maria comey ajino with the white pieces
inna agrest
and solid thus far we started in a
spanish that looks sort of like an
italian because
uh not to in piece of interest this
bishop is well not two no pieces have
been traded the bishop's on the diagonal
towards the enemy king this knight can
come to g3 or
e3 as it happens in the italian very
often
so anna are we going to see a capture
next move for white or are we gonna have
to wait a few more four pieces are
getting traded
you know it's pretty uncommon that 13
moves go and there's been no trade
whatsoever
but um yeah i'm i'm not sure if
if i don't think that black is one is
going to want to trade on a4 because
when black trades on a4 what happens
then is that the a file gets open for
the work and that a6 pawn could be
in some trouble at some point although
what is also true is that
the b file becomes open so there are
there are
goods and bats but i don't really think
that they're going to take yet i think
they would rather reinforce that pawn on
b5
and that's what inagurus is doing by
going c6
that's right and white can't take on b5
at any moment
it's not like black is going to take on
a4 as you were saying so that's why
instead of capturing we see d4
well now other pawns can be captured but
does white want to take on
e5 does black want to take on d4 these
are difficult questions to answer at
first glance
taking on d4 allows white to get these
strong pawns and you don't have a pawn
on the e5 blocking so essentially you
give white
two pawns in the center to your one that
typically is an advantage
for the side with the two because those
pawns can push and pawns in the center
restrict pieces
very well so i don't think that you know
we'll be taking
on d4s trying to figure out another way
even though e64 is not a blunder
it's not that big of a deal it just
becomes a difficult strategic battle
after that
maybe something that black would want to
do is to go c5 to just
uh to just try to get a little bit more
control of the centers that this two
versus one thing doesn't happen
i like the idea of c5 for sure she plays
queen e7
first and she's just keeping the status
quo i would jump my knight to g3
try to land that knight on f5 because
even if it's captured if i take with the
e pawn my rook wins the battle against
your queen
down the e line so knight g3 standard
move regardless the position
but i think it's has more punch right
now with the follow up being knight f5 i
think that white station is
good let's move on to the one game we
haven't checked out yet
between hannah marie kleck the sole
victor for gronka bank in the previous
round in the semifinals
she takes on maxine lavrov and and i
have to admit i
really like white's position this was
the four nights game and
the bishop on d3 looks really good
staring at the h7 square
now that we're trading off this knight
on f6 yep
that knight on f6 is typically the big
defender
uh on on that on this h7 checkmate and
we can see that that bishop on the three
is pointing right at h7
and probably is going to be joined by
the queen very soon as well
and while the asia here becomes as well
that if g6 is ever played well then the
h6 pawn is going to become very weak
and that black's pieces seem to be a
little bit uncoordinated
to defend on the king side so for
instance rook on b4 although it is the
it is attacking on c4 it's also not
really helping out on the defense and i
think that
soon black's pieces are going to have to
defend that's absolutely correct
and this pawn d5 is under attack because
the queen helps out
so white is threatened to win a pawn but
more importantly the attack because you
could take on c4 thinking
wait i can win your pawn and after pawn
takes oh let me take with that bishop
here and you're going to see the eval
bar yep i knew that was coming
because this is a blunder and the reason
why is look at this
situation piecer in a row looks defended
but i can even make a move like queen to
h4
potentially a queen to c5 type of move
and the reason why queen c5 can be
played
is there are so many pieces under attack
including this rook on fa just to show
you a sample variation
if you go queen b6 i have bishop h7
check as a possibility
your king can take and the queen takes
this rook here white can steal some
material
with an attack to boot yeah
very nice line so because we have to
work on before being unprotected could
become a weakness for black
i also think that quite soon we're going
to be seeing a rick lift perhaps for
white
uh those rooks i think are gonna start
getting into the game yes rookie four
rookie three type of moves
i would take back here i think you
should probably deal with the pawn first
although i was talking about the pin
rookie four is a possibility because
this rook is hanging
queen h4 or queen g4 one of these type
of moves is possible
trying to pin this pawn but queen see if
i played going for the check
going for the check yes and
the question then becomes can black just
take on d3 and say
all right we're giving an exchange we're
sacrificing an exchange
but that pawn on d3 could become strong
and this is our
best shot basically yeah it actually
doesn't hate it
this advantage is for white but we knew
that going in
at least that gives good compensation as
the bishop will stay protecting it
i think that it's going to be relatively
easy
game for white not to win but just to
play going forward you can blockade the
pawn on a dark square
bring your other rook maybe into e7 so
white has the upper hand
but it will not be an easy conversion so
uh the queen's e5 is
a very good move i'm just looking at the
other games to make sure
we're not missing anything substantial
the game's still going on some of them
closed positions
i'm going to quickly hop to this game
we'll come right back i see a lot of
trades
so white has the rooks on the e file
very good rooks
but bad pawns so it's the evil bars is
black is slightly better
i look at this think that white has a
pretty good initiative going on
whose position would you take whites or
black i would take whites from just the
first glance
and because it seems that white just has
so active pieces
but i guess that the reason why they
feel like
black is a bit better do you think it's
because of white's pawn structure
it must be but i think it's easier to
blunder as black rook c7 falls into
knight a6
you can't kick my knight out of the c5
square my rook's on the e file hitting
the c6 pawn
i think white's in no danger whatsoever
right now i would prefer the position
and if we trade the rooks this is
high level but if you can visualize say
these rooks are gone
all four rooks there could be an outside
past pawn situation
that i can throw through so that's later
in the game
i want to go back to this game because
the tactical moment
was avoided rook b8 played the very
safe move defending this rook so bishop
h7 doesn't work
pawn takes c4 i still prefer white's
position thanks to this bishop
the bishop on e6 is not nearly as strong
but perhaps black is one move away just
one from
surviving this initiative maybe it could
be rook to d8
or rook to e8 one of these rooks here
yeah very close but perhaps they
perhaps they are they are close enough
to able to survive this
so yeah it seems like it looked better
before than what we have right now
but as you said i think that white is a
little bit better as well because of
this bishop and perhaps because you know
i don't know if the rick goes to d8 for
instance and we see something like queen
f5 i guess that idea is then just to go
g6 right and that's the way of defending
you were right to point out when the
queen is on h5 g6 was not possible but
you wait till the queen goes away
now the pawn is not under attack so it
looks like you can parry the immediate
threat
and i will just say at this moment here
it felt like the
tactical ideas were working better than
keeping the material equal so
i would have gone for pawn takes c4 i
didn't calculate it all through but it
looked like a position where
black would have had a difficult time
trying to stave off all the threats but
queen f4 played
that gives up the c6 pawn it also gives
up the a7 pawn
so maybe it's the right choice henry
collects says all right i
kept the tension alive i didn't give up
material and now she can scoop off
either pawn i would take on a7 i like
that pawn to capture
yeah it feels like the c6 pawn is always
going to be a weakness anyways and also
if you
if you take the c6 pawn you're opening
up the sea fall which could perhaps lead
to rick
putting some pressure on the c4 pond so
it seems like it's
uh just very natural to take the a7 pawn
and she goes for the rook left look at
that you
you mentioned the rook left early
pawns i'm not going for the pawns i'm
going for the king
and this pawn isn't going anywhere this
pawn won't be captured next because the
bishop
will go to b7 but that a7 pawn is a
problem and rook g4
looks pretty scary too yeah so so
she's going for the king attack and for
the work lift but
i think that at some point taking those
pawns has to be really good as well
agreed and let's go to the top board
i'll keep an eye
on this one between garrick meyer and
young napoli because in
that game i just see way too many pieces
to know what's going on
all four minor pieces both sides have
those six pawns each i thought that
there were more pawns because i saw
these bishops and i assumed one of them
was a pawn
but no those are bishops the bishop on
g3 i think we can agree
not of exactly a very powerful bishop
the bishop on g2
full length and diagonal but empty space
and one of the main questions
i have is can white at some point play
e4
well that palm was just taken didn't
even see that pawn was hanging i wasn't
i was looking at the center and all the
pieces
jan takes the pawn but the engine didn't
love it
you know robert maybe now that the queen
is gone maybe now that
now e4 could be an idea that's what you
were mentioning and perhaps you can just
go e for now
um okay are you going for rick a1 first
she put some pressure on a7 as well
you know the main drawback of e4 is that
the d4 square but there's no knight d4
because after knight takes d4
our queens stare at each other yours is
not defended and my knight can recapture
on c2 if you take my queen so
that's probably part of the reason why
e4 was available there
and instead york puts the rook on a6
that rook
darts over the queen side cements the
pawn in place
attacks this knight on e6 keep and the
queen tied down and i don't see a plan
for black that's part of the problem
bishop f7
what is this i've never seen a
configuration like this before
you know very interesting george just
offered a draw
right before well right after rook a6
and and
iron by going bishop f7 declined that
draw
i don't know who thinks they're better
maybe both sides just think it's
interesting
there is a second uh match right so even
if you lose the game now your
team gets to come back by the way alina
keschlinska and
alexander kudaski have drawn their game
on board two we thought that was pretty
level
so knight d6 played by george the c5
pawn is now under attack the bishop is
under attack
pressure on f5 but then again the
evaluation bar says that wasn't the best
move like you had something better but
why is that not a good move just the
calm bishop g8
look at that bit i mean this whole
configuration of pieces
is just so interesting how they're all
kind of together
on the king side almost no pieces on on
the queen side
i don't i haven't seen something like
this to be honest no and
what the way i would define this
position is headache inducing because
i don't know what to do as there's too
many pieces i want to
trade something i i feel like i need to
be quick here if i'm white and
york says i'm not going to be quick on
h3 i don't know the exact purpose of
that move it does give the king a square
off the back rank
but this bishop on g3 remains a problem
so i think that yon if he's careful
he can have the upper hand here but for
now it's too crowded the board so i'm
going to go to
inna aggressive scheme she's playing on
board four so let's go there
she's taking on maria comey gina and
speaking of rook lifts if you take on e3
or nazi gun b6 there could be a rook
lift at some point
but that look at that here we go rook a7
this rook can
go to d6 to take the d file whose rooks
are going to be better in this game anna
that is a great question i don't really
see
how the rooks on the a file could
immediately cause
any problem um i mean they
they are great on the a file or they
look great on the a file but i'm not
really sure where they're going to be
honest
right the f7 pawn you can't attack it
because this pawn c4 is such a
annoying piece your bishop on c2 doesn't
look very good and one rook on d8 the
other
come to d6 this bishop can develop out
here and this knight on h4
is it happy here it wanted to go to f5
but if it does
black can just snap it off the board so
queen e2 play to get the queen save
and i think rook to d6 makes sense try
to land their work on d2
yep i think that rick detrow is a much
bigger threat than any
brook in the a fell could create anytime
soon but
okay she's going queen c5 instead
um she's going queen c5 instead
and that sets up rook to d6 and so as
they're blocking the queen in
this queen is already active on c5 it
attacks that rook on a7 so i think white
has to be careful here
maria she is up over a minute on the
clock that's good news for
for her but inna is starting to seize
the initiative her pieces are getting
active
rook a5 puts pressure on this b-pawn
that b-pawn's very well defended not a
big deal i think you can still slide the
rook to d6
and try to play for more so let's uh
move on quickly
to the game that we were looking at in
detail how to make clock i saw this at
the corner of my eye which is why i had
to go here
look at this position look at the eval
bar you say wait why is it so good
isn't this just the position where it's
even material after queen takes c6 was
just played
where's that bishop going right bishop
is cannot really go anywhere because if
bishop c8 the rook on a8 is hanging
the rook on a8 is hanging so the bishop
can't go to see it to
save it the bishop's under attack that
leaves him like queen a5
queen d2 played to attack the rook and
the bishop on d3
but here comes this rook here comes the
second rook and rooks on the seventh
rank are just devastating
they absolutely are they're going to be
completely devastating so many rook
lifts we've seen today robert
okay maybe not a rook lift yet but the
potential of seeing them
rook f7 sacrificing for checkmate i
think that's the way to go here just
take on f7 remove the defender of the g6
pawn
and i don't think that black can really
survive i guess black will sacrifice
the q or actually made it to rook f7
this queen takes d3 so i
should be a little more careful with
that wow this is
a little more complicated than thought
so maybe just rookie three that's rook
left second rook left
oh maybe there was an opportunity after
queen 63 i don't know if you could go
queen e7
because then that seventh rank was
really
really really vulnerable but i'm not
sure perhaps there was a way of
doing that the end engine justifies it
plus six even though you're down a piece
for a couple pawns so
if rook takes f7 had to be the move i
kind of talked myself out of it but
rook b won rookie eight and all of a
sudden black's trying to
fend off the attack and attack the queen
instead but queen d5
puts more pressure and there's pressure
in all directions
this rook on eight still under attack
the pawn f7
is threatened no this queen d5 quizzes
six also good
same ideas before yeah and now my team i
mean he's getting into very very very
uh low very low time he has 45 seconds
left
so he's gotta have to play fast it
really feels like
hannah just has just has the very big
advantage both
with the position but also with the time
so it's probably it's probably gonna be
it's probably gonna be a i don't know
can we say that it can be it's gonna be
a win here can we say that already
i'm scared of saying that because i feel
like i'm going to jinx it but yeah i
think we can say that and especially
right now bishop takes g6 the queen
comes over this king is
has no defenders so a nice game here by
henry kleck
she was the reason grunky moved on by
winning her game
her opponent dropped a rook unexpectedly
but if she wins this she's showing that
hey i'm here and i'm ready to help our
team to the championship
and if she plays bishop takes g6 i think
the game will
and there it is the game will be over in
just a few moves rook f8 doesn't even
help you can still take on f7
because this rook on a that's been a
problematic piece this whole way through
yeah it definitely has and we're finally
seeing isaac and
yeah ricky won now but the king can just
just escape to h2 there's not really any
big issue there
and now everything's hanging the bishop
on a6 the rook on a the pawn f7
and if you take on g6 i can even just
take back and meet you just
okay rook g3 is probably good g3 is also
good there are no bad moves in this
position
no no absolutely not i see here that
um yeah the brick is hanging i mean
everything is hanging this is just one
of those type of positions and you only
have six
five seconds left yeah so we have to go
to speaking of five seconds
after this game concludes or maybe right
now gotta go to george meyer against
yon apameshi because that game that we
know this one's going to be over in
white's favor
this game barely getting that rook back
to defend the last rank
york has eight seconds and he's
unfortunately down a pawn so it looks
like
the other game did just conclude in
white's favor and now
you're trying desperately to hold here
he's down the pawn
his king is weak his 9.5 seconds anna
can you do it
doesn't look like it i don't think so i
think this is looking very very tough
i mean he's a great blitz player but
seven seconds it's extremely hard and
that b-pawn is just pushing although now
well rick b6 but i don't know if you can
even go b2
yeah exactly very beautiful move what a
way to
try to finish this game if that queen
was captured the rook would take back
and it would have been supporting
the queening square so now whoa whoa
both players missing things you saw that
eval bar drop
like crazy and that must mean oh my gosh
could have taken on b2 the bishop was
pinned oh wow
missed the chance there to take the pawn
and now rook b8 happens
and you're in a losing position and
you're resigning yeah
wow just to show that everybody what a
sequence here
b2 if you take the queen the rook
replaces it
can't stop me from promoting the best
you sacrifice your queen for the new
queen
and after what was played uh b2
uh when the queen went to f5 here
queen c7 this pawn could be captured the
bishop is pinned so missed opportunity
let's go to the final game
that's still going the score is one and
a half one and a half and
this position oh my gosh it's
wow final game with one and a half one
and a half that's very exciting all
stakes are on this game
and you know they will no matter what
get a second match but you're right
having the lead taking control of the
match going to the second
second one this looks promising for
white at this point but don't take this
pawn too soon there's g5 check
which would be a fork maybe e5 i would
try to play for e5 there good
yeah now the knight is stopping any e5
type of move but she had g5
i understand with not that much time
playing any kind of pawn move
can be worrisome but look at the eval
bar turning in black's favor all of a
sudden maybe this rook will slide to a6
and use the open file absolutely
absolutely they're both just trying to
get there and now g5
the h3 pawn that was hanging and h3 pawn
is hanging
she doesn't have much time though rook
takes but h3 is still hanging
and you don't want to drop that pawn too
no she's defending it but that's not a
good move and you don't want
it you had to defend it but it's not a
move you want to play and this rook is
in
rook g1 rook g3 anybody bring that rook
up
rook do you want now she's playing
workout she needs to find rook she won
she's not finding ricky one are they
going to go back oh my gosh
that's a huge shame for inaugura she
actually had the upper hand here and she
didn't have much time
and you get nervous you're playing for
your team but when this rook comes to g1
and to g3 down goes h3 attacks the pawn
c3
and black is probably already winning
objectively at this point you see the
evaluation
showing in black's favor and i can't
really blame her
she doesn't want to lose the game that
would be the worst thing she played well
with the black pieces in the next
set of games she gets the white pieces
so maybe just drawing with black
you know as a result for the team that's
a good thing two to two anna
we could not have a closer match
it's so close and now i can actually say
that all stakes are gonna be on this
very last match it's going to be so
exciting to follow all of these games
and i mean i really really can't wait
yes and i'm just trying to get
confirmation on
when the next round is to remind you all
to stay put don't go anywhere it's two
to two we not we're not getting into
blitz just yet
we will have another set of these rapid
time control
uh games and the next one will be in
15 minutes at 5-0 50
past the hour so 10 minutes before the
next hour that will be when the next
games take place which means we are
going to go on a short break but before
we do
just a reminder that this event is about
raising awareness
raising money for great initiatives for
players with disabilities
for veteran chess players and for chess
and education so if you can please do
show your support your generosity is
appreciated so many of you
have been taking part and give your
donations it is
seriously thank you from the bottom of
my heart but for now and i will take a
break
when we return we'll come back for the
final match of the
final of the fide world corporate chess
[Music]
championship
do
[Music]
so
welcome back everybody to the fide world
corporate championship this is the
finals anna
we had a break we were relaxing for a
little do you think the players could
relax at all
i think that they're nervous this
finished up in two two so
everything is set for this very last
match and this match is going to decide
who the winner
of the feed online world corporate chess
championship is so
it's going to be a very exciting match
and i'm really looking forward to it
what would you have done if you have a
break between matches would you prepare
it all or would you just try to
erase chest from your mind for a few
minutes
take a breath of fresh air just like go
to the window
maybe you know just eat something how do
you approach this
preparation or relaxation
i would say relaxation i mean i know
that
i get nervous so i would probably have
ended up preparing something anyway sort
of like with an exam
you just you know that you should not be
studying
five minutes before the test when you're
walking into a room but you end up doing
it anyway but
i think that really the best thing is
just to relax take something to eat
maybe bring a glass of water
get some air whatever it is that makes
you relax because then
that that will really that'll really
just set you in the mood for the game i
think
for sure and we'll remind everybody of
how we got here
which teams remaining it is gronky bank
taking on
spare in the finals you see half half
because they split
the first match uh it's two to two of
the four games
gronkey defeated onowak and also pt in
that
oh that was a tough finish for pt and on
the other side of things spare
defeats erg and then beats spare bank
trade union which was led by
anton korbov another super grand master
so spare with yon upanishi on the top
board
gromke garg meyer but honestly this has
been about some of the
other boards and that's what happens in
team events it's not just the super
grand master at the top
no hannah marie kleck has had a great
showing she won
in the semifinals she just won the first
game of the finals
so she's been the mvp for gronkey
absolutely absolutely so really you
cannot just look at one board
and decide from that board you know
who's the strongest player that's the
team that's gonna win no this is a team
championship
and it's all about the four boards
so robert do you have do you have
any prediction or sort of do do do you
know who do you who you think that's
gonna win or how are you feeling about
this last match
yeah i have a prediction for you chess
is going to be played that's my
prediction
and we see the gronky team on screen
here
and for those of you wondering every
single team gets one free agent
and grandmaster georg meyer the number
one player
for this team he works at grunke so he
is not the free agent a lot of the teams
with grandmasters
that's the free agent but no here it's
elina kaslinskaya
who was brought in at the rating 2494
you're only allowed one player over 2500
so they chose her at 24.94 she's very
experienced
very well prepared super strong is a
great person
as well so i think she's proven to be a
fantastic
addition to this team and for georg and
the crew
one match four games remain and the
games
are starting yon napomshi gets the
white pieces against george meyer he did
beat york he's beaten ants on corbett
before that so he has proven that he is
an elite player
and he's doing the best he can for spare
absolutely we're seeing here the game's
starting they've switched the board so
now ayan is playing with the white
pieces so we're gonna see some new
some new openings in new repertoires but
i feel like we've seen a lot of
bishops on you on g2 this
uh this championship or at least today
feels like almost every bishop has gone
to g2 and there'd be a lot of
fianchettos so we're seeing another one
in this game with g3 bishop g2
yeah this bishop came to g2 the long
diagonal the bishop on c8
will not be quite as strong and the
queens are traded that does not mean
it's just equal or boring
blacks can have a tough time finishing
development bishop comes to g2
it attacks his pawn on b7 and black and
castle queenside but sometimes you
castle queenside
without queens in the board and there
still is a potential attack white has an
extra pawn
on the queen side so after bishop g2 you
can think about a4 pushing some pawns of
the board
and if the king goes to c8 perhaps the
black king will
find safety but it won't be that easy
nope it won't be that easy and that's a
really good point that you're making
that you know white has one extra pawn
on the queen side
so sometimes you can sort of think about
that
for in games for instance a lot of times
when that when the king is is castling
on the king's side that x and the king
is really far away from the queen side
that extra pawn on the queen side could
really make a difference when entering
an
end game we can see now that the king
has castle queen side oh
that's a good point and an illustration
of that as those pawn scene
start pushing and you would say black
shut up the advantage
i didn't mean to take the pawn black
should have an advantage because of the
pawn on e6
that's upon the center but the problem
is creating a pass pawn for black is
much more difficult
in these end games because the king is
closer to the center
you want to keep the king close to
center of the end game so a4 is played
by young
he also has ideas of knight b5 bishop f4
and if you're not careful for gear you
could find your king
falling victim to an attack so let's
keep on going let's go to board two
alina kashlinskaya is taking on
graffiti master alexander kadatsky and
well she is just locked into the screen
here that's what happens when you're
playing chess
at first you're oh this is the best
camera angle for me you forget that
you're on camera
because you're so focused on the board
on the play and anna
we have another fianchetto but we have
matching
fianchettos and opposite the board so
who's king
is gonna be under attack my opinion
looks like white has the safe for the
two kings
but what do you think i think that i
i think i agree with you i kind of feel
like
white's attack on the black king could
be
could be could be quite quick like just
you know just
just going something like i know f3 g4
h4 all of that is happening very quickly
and i can't really see exactly how black
is going to attack the white king yet
because something like
i mean b5 b4 would not really leech
anything so i guess then
b5 a5 but then the b5 pawn is going to
be hanging so
it seems like it's going to take quite a
long time for black to attack the white
king
you just illustrate that very well and
the hero
is the f3 pawn because there are more
pawns for white
we're trying to attack black doesn't
have a pawn on c6
so that you can then play a5 so this
pawn on f3 defends the center
and also helps these pawns go forward so
black's
quote unquote attack not really picking
up steam anytime
soon and i think this can be extremely
dangerous and alina also
is well ahead in the clock nearly two
minutes at this point and her plan to
push forward
as you said more straightforward and
it's not going to be
simple as let's go get a checkmate
because i push my pawns up black can
defend it just feels
easier to play at this point for alina
yeah i totally agree
i totally agree so it's gonna be
exciting to see what happens in this
game
we will keep an eye on it let's go to
the board three keep on
going down the line up we have hannah
marie kleck with the black pieces so far
winning
her games for grand quebec and you have
maxine lavrov with the white his
international master
and look at this position this knight on
d4 pawn and d5 say
let me take advantage of the c6 square
but black often
can say i'll put my bishop on d7 or i'll
put my bishop on b7
to attack your pawn at some point and
this pawn on d5 can actually be
over extended so i think white wants to
play f4
to get the knight into c6 but what he's
quickly recognizing
is that after f4 while that looks good
i'm attacking the knight
black can throw in in a shot against the
queen
your queen has only one safe square to
go to queen of d2
and now my knight comes in with tempo so
you don't get knight c6
winning a piece that's what you want is
if this knight goes to d7 you get knight
c6
that ends the game in white's favor but
because you throw on bishop to g4
you can play knight c4 and then you get
some time to regroup
yep very very good point that bishop g4
was a very nice move but it was not
played
by hannah instead she played c5 in this
position
what a move c5 would never even consider
it she knows
he's just giving a pun but it's filling
the square that's her idea she she's
filling the square so the knight can't
go here
and i guess her claim anna is she'll get
that pawn back later
and it's justified according to the
engine she is better
according to the computer very cool move
that really i mean
yeah i did not think about that move at
all but
yeah wow that's that's that's such a
cool moose i guess that now now maybe
she can go for the same idea as you said
before with bishop g4
just to you know develop her pieces
immediately and get that rick to c8 or
queen to c7 to attack that pawn
she's going for 94 instead but oh now
the evaluation that's starting to go
up and up for white the extra pawn i
guess is going to feel safe
if this knight can land on d5 black's
position
is in trouble so i would look for that i
know that if this queen lands on h4 for
black all of a sudden
there's some counter play so maybe like
a d5 bishop c5
queen h4 that's the kind of quick moves
you need for
black in a position like this where
you're down material yep but it might
take a while that's
uh that station i'm not really sure
where this
knight is going now if let's say for
instance
h3 is the knight then just to go the
idea just to go back to f6
oh now you can't but okay queen b6 this
makes sense if you get a
turn you can pile up on this knight on
d4 so h3
while it may try to win this on g4 your
knight on d4
is also falling victim to an attack so
actually it was much trickier because
knight c3 was the move i said
and yet bishop f6 played him the eval
bar goes down
so i don't know what white possibly
missed there
nicely look like such a normal move but
that's how tricky chess can be where
yeah if you have the engine as your
assistant you can play all the best
moves
without it it's a complicated game of
course but
we're trying to work through the
complications and help you out but queen
b6 now the threat
there also could be an idea of bishop
takes and queen h4 if you're not careful
hitting the h2 pawn and the rook on e1
so if you play some careless movie a3
and we get some situation like this
queen h4 let me drop the queen there
hits the rook and hits the pawn so white
is the one who suddenly needs to be
careful
yeah now you have to be very careful in
these type of situations there are many
tactics
and yeah some ideas like
like uh like queen b6 could also be
perhaps played but she's going for h3
now
all right he's going for h3 now max him
i think you have to play queen b you're
not playing your knight back on h6 that
looks bad queen b6 played
there's no easy way to defend this
knight because you don't want to bring
your knight back to e2
like this you can probably get away with
it and actually it's what's played
but black instead of going to h6 going
knight back to e5
thanks to tactics you take my knight oh
it's a knife for a pawn
well i'll do the same thing right back
to you i will eventually win your pawn
on c6 and you see the evil voice is
zeroes because of course it's always
zeros and chess
that's actually really cool it feels
like white has played very natural moves
but still
now the evil bar is not really
it's not really thinking that that white
is as as has the great position that
they said that they
that they had before so it's really
interesting how
how hannah played this i think yes very
like active chess right just throwing
the pieces forward
playing c5 which all right the engine
says not
the best she'll review the game after
and figure out where
she could have improved but this was a
very enterprising style
and now after 95 one more move i take
this pawn and as we're discussing you
take i take
bishops love open space and this king on
g1 could find itself in trouble
especially if this pawn is taken
and the bishop gets to b7 that's a very
long diagonal to work with so let's go
to board
four we have been here for a while ina
agressed with the white pieces she drew
that game with black
in game one where she actually had the
upper hand at the end of the game but
time trouble
would not allow her to play for the win
at that moment she felt like she needed
to just hold
but we talked about this in a different
game anna are we just gonna see a g4 and
a
quick attack i think so i think we're
gonna see a g4
um yeah i i definitely think so i think
that that's just kind of
how you want to continue the attack um
to start pushing those pawns i mean i
don't really know if you want to go for
instance if you would like to keep your
pawn in g2 to at some point go e5 and
have that g2 pawn defending f3
um i'm thinking e5 to open up the light
square bishop
but yeah in general i think that that's
the sort of ideas we're going to be
seeing but instead
inna went for bishop e3 in this position
to
to kick the queen away i think she
doesn't want to concern herself with a5
and now the queen and bishop line up on
the b5 pawn so a5 not possible
she's playing maybe a bit reserved at
the moment her pieces are still better
but if you're not careful and you just
say oh i'm solid i don't need to do
anything
black plays d5 so it's opening up the
board for
her pieces and then black could try to
take advantage of it so i think that
bishop d2 okay i see the point don't
play rook d8
you'd lose the rook thanks to bishop a5
knight a5
is another thing to consider i i like
this it may be
quieter than i would have played had i
had the white pieces going for g4
but she's not committing herself to
anything and if d5 now she could play e5
you mentioned this idea
this would be a dream come true for the
bishop on d3
yep absolutely a bishop on d3 is not
really
doing a lot right now of course it's
defending c2 but
it's uh it's almost like a big pawn
that's typically what you say when when
there's a pawn right in front of the
bishop it sort of becomes like a pawn
itself so
to give that bishop some life that would
that would be a dream come true
but i kind of like the fact that she's
trying to position her pieces
in in a good way and she's not really
making any big decisions with her pawns
yet
and e5 plates is to emphasize what ana
just said that bishop on d3 is not going
anywhere
and you could still play g4 this might
be the moment to do so another idea
is say rook c1 and c4 because your king
is actually quite safe on b1
and you can improve your bishop and also
open up the queen side
but you're looking at d5 as well that's
kind of a scary move
to see so g4 either taking on h5 or
pushing through the g5
and there it is you know plays it she
times it well her advantage is still
there according to the engine but i
think both players recognizing it's not
you're not thinking in terms of numbers
you think well is this king going to be
safe because the answer is no what will
just win the game
and if black can find out a way to just
keep
safe for the time being maybe she'll be
able to counter on the queen seven anna
i'm looking at the game between georg
and jan
that one's really deep into the end game
where yon just played the move
rook lift rook a4 and on one hand this
pawn a5 could be seen as a weakness if
in a king and pawn end game you can go
win it
but for now it could be seen as a
strength because maybe rook before
rook b6 and use that pawn to help plant
the rook on b6
exactly yeah and if that pawn is not
lost then that pawn is also
that one single pawn on a5 could be stop
is stopping the movement of both the b7
pawn and the a6 pawn so that one pawn is
controlling
those two pawns so in general as long as
that pawn is not lost
it is a it is a very strong pawn and if
you can reinforce that pawn with b4 for
instance i think that that's
that's definitely that's definitely a a
good pawn
so yeah look at the knights here the 96
is actually a good defender
the knight on e4 is an aggressor and
white's pawns are kind of perfectly
placed the c3 pawn takes away d4
the g3 pawn takes away f f4 the h4 pawn
takes away g5
the knight has nowhere to improve at
least not from this position
whereas the knight e4 maybe doesn't have
anywhere to improve to but it looks
strong here in the center definitely and
if that knight on e6 ever moves there's
gonna be a knight c5
coming in and that could perhaps be very
strong as well but
now instead ian is going for rick before
to put some pressure on
b7 and just like you said perhaps he
wants to put his k his work on b6
and because there the rick would be
would be very strong and would also be
putting pressure onto b7 i think york
has to get passive now you don't want to
it's an
end game you just can't afford to drop
pawns or allow this knight to infiltrate
more you mentioned the c5 square i would
love to get there
but knight d8 maybe you just have to say
i don't like it
but i'll go d8 maybe king to c7 or c8
defend this pawn and king c7 rook to b6
i'm already attacking your knight so you
have to move
regardless and then i probably will end
up on this d8 square
sorry doesn't look fun i don't like it
it's
defensive and white is taking control
over most of the action but i think york
has to do it has to quickly look at the
time he's two minutes and 40 seconds
to yawns five minutes and 40 seconds the
thing is that it's always
easier to attack than to defend i think
and that can also be seen in the time
control
in in the time that if you are defending
it's it's not as fun and you're probably
gonna perhaps
think a little bit more if you're
attacking the new the moves just come
very natural to you
well speaking of attacking defending i
need to switch games right now because i
just saw the move played here
between henry kleck and maxine lavrov
then move with knight e6
and that knight gets up in there hitting
the rook the pawn can't take on e6
because the rook and f8 is hanging
and you're also hitting the pawn f7
three times
all of your firepower aimed towards that
black king
and rook e4 played tricky move but uh
there's got to be a mate
probably just rook takes up seven right
trying to go over cafe it's
there's nothing you can do about it it's
just checkmate there i played
and no matter what you do you can move
the rook anywhere if you take on f7 the
queen replaces the rook and then goes to
f8
you're getting checked made out of fate
you see mate in two moves on softball
unstoppable absolutely unstoppable
and this happened so quickly i mean in
this position
black was the one we mentioned this idea
that looks really good
and then queen h6 all right oh the
rook's e7 rook c4 rook f1 and just not
sensing the danger
of this knight coming here and play
bishop c6
maybe bishop c8 is necessarily something
like that but knight e6
that's a winning position now for white
and for team spare
what a nice move that 96 it's just one
of those tactics that
if you haven't seen it it really just
completely surprises you because you
really were not expecting that in that
position
that was a very very nice find by maxine
labroff agreed and let's go
well this game is about to end we'll if
the conclude soon we'll show the final
position the game's
lena kashlinskaya and alexander kadatsky
you said
attacking is easier than defending how
about this there's a knight on f5
white is down a piece it was a sacrifice
to get here just a couple moves ago
queen e7 knight takes h5 pawn takes
knight f5 you tell us about the garry
kasparov quote right knight's in f5
it's like almost a win guaranteed and
that knight can't be kicked out
h5 is under attack h6 e7
d6 where does this queen even go f8
that's
that feels like a sad move to play it's
not where it wants to be and after queen
takes h5 there's
some extra pressure being put on that
bishop and i think that now it's time
for the rook lift
the famous work-lift rook for rook d4
oh yes because you can even take on e5
bring your rook to
this is just powering through crushing
and looks like elena kashlinsky the free
agent for
gronka bank this is a winning position
she knows it
i'm sure that cadetsky knows it well
he's hoping that somehow he can weasel
his way out of this
it just then i can't move the knight
moves the bishop is hanging there's a
knight in f5
yeah no and this is brilliant
rook f4 there we have it you called for
it the players said i
simply must and this is happening before
you know it
this king has nowhere to go yeah now
this is
uh this seems to just be completely
crushing very very very
nice game by alina here instructive play
and rookie you can even take on d6 i
probably would not take that pawn
doesn't feel necessary rook g4 we've
been mentioning this idea
oh wait you take the knight but then i
can take on g7 and your queen is trapped
so the best you can do is give up that
queen for the bishop and this knight on
g4 is also under attack your king is
going to remain unsafe
and you see the eval bar completely
winning for white so i'm just gonna
corner my eye look at the other two
games it looks like the
the end game still going on between
georg and yan
the game between ina agrest still plenty
of life in that
so i'll let's see if uh alina can
land the knockout that's what i want to
see is she going to play rook to g4
is she just going to take on d6 now the
rook moved out the way what do you think
she does
taking on d6 seems kind of good because
obviously
it's a pawn and you activate uh you're
activating another piece you're
activating your your other work but
i also feel like yeah she's going for
rook g4 i just felt like that pawn on d6
was really stopping the queen from
having any movement so it's very pretty
that after knight takes g4
there's bishop takes g7 and the queen is
trapped
yes and you make a good point about you
know the pawn is free you bring a piece
in
but you also give black a little bit of
time whereas rook g4 is forcing you're
threatening rook takes g7 your knight is
helping out
this knight in f5 it's too strong and
knight g6 does not help you
because bishop takes g7 still traps that
queen so white is going to win here
very nice alina will even up the match
because
spare won with maxine lavrov and let's
go to
another game because we know the results
that's going to happen here let's go to
ina agrest
game we haven't checked in around
against maria comey and gina where
it says zeros every time we tune into a
position it says zeros we're like wait
why is this completely equal it's not
there's plenty of life left even on the
clock though both players at a minute 50
about
would you take white or black ignoring
the the evaluation bar for a second
that is a very good question um i kind
of like that black has the idea of going
a5 a4 and that they can push that a pawn
i feel like
white's attack on the king's side has
sort of
stagnated here and it has sort of
stopped so
and in that regard i like it i'm not
really sure where this bishop is going
to go now
that's what i'm trying to to figure out
oh that's uh important i would play rook
d5
because you give yourself the c5 square
and you want to play rook d5 regardless
you think i can't do it i'll lose my
bishop but the rook d5 move would have
saved it although now
that might be a pawn worth capturing
that's yup there's a chromosome before
that e4 pawn seems to be a strong a very
important pawn in this game also because
that e5 pawn it's going to be
could become a very very very strong
past pawn
in the end game although free pawns can
be deceiving you take the pawn and then
you allow these rooks to come in and
then
attack your pawn the e5 pawn is more
important to the defense of black's king
and we did see a victory by elena
kashlinska no surprise there she had won
her opponent's queen
and in this game rookie 2 played i feel
like white has a clear plan now so even
though you're down material
at least your next few moves your next
idea
is more obvious and queen g4 played
don't take on e5 you drop a rook here
can you just
play rookie one and try to pile up
yep and i mean that if i pawn
okay they're going rick d2 instead so
they're not really going for the e5 pawn
instead of trying to double up on the
default um
bishop f fade that's a good move that's
a really good move trying to play bishop
g7 you can't play e4
if the bishop comes in d4 and the queen
comes f6 you get checkmated but if your
bishop comes to g7 that helps your king
preemptively yep no i really like that
meme as well
queen e6 now the queen is leaving g4
do you think that yeah i don't yeah you
shouldn't really go
e4 just yet right e4 is too early here
i wouldn't rush that move and we're
gonna just go between both games there's
only two games left and decides
who is the fiji world corporate champion
actually the other game just finishing
the draw is about to bring us they'll
show the board
really quickly that game finished as a
draw so
george meyer putting up amazing defense
his position did look worse but his rook
got very active and just went around and
they repeated moves here
uh they agreed to a draw but you see the
engine evaluation zero black can't move
this knight or this king
the b7 pawn and all of white's pawns are
defended for now so a draw was agreed
let's go back to the only game remaining
and it is an even match so let's
switch here this game all the marbles
black has
25 seconds of counting down but an extra
pawn i would rather have the time oh no
rook d a check queen of fame just
changed everything
she found it she finds it and inna
agress is about to win grenkey
the world corporate championship this
king is hunted down
i've had the feeling that taking on e4
would give white easier play
and look at that queen f8 threatens mate
threatens mate threatens mate on g8 as
well you cannot stop all three
checkmates you don't have a single check
for the black pieces that's made by
force wow
once again what a way to finish
a game we were saying that you know this
is going to be a long game where black
would have to
try to to to convert this into a win
being upon up but this just
ended immediately after this one move
which was not you know
super super easy to see immediately but
there's just this checkmate
and one of the players look at them
they're so happy they're smiling
they're all really good friends and
alina they're smiling joining them as
the free agent
that's a wonderful achievement because
they had their backs against the wall it
was 2-2 after the first match
in this match georg was being pressured
by
yon napomishi you see them talking
they're of course in a zoom call
these were fair play measures to make
sure that the arbiters could see all the
players see their screens and everything
to uphold fair play but look at them
it's what i love to see it's just
pure joy they just played an epic final
match
and they're look at them all across
those four
faces just smiles all around it's just
absolutely amazing to see that and i
think especially the feeling when you're
playing in a team
it's just even more amazing to win
because it's not just you but you can
share the happiness about winning with
other
people and the people that you're
working with here it's just
absolutely amazing to see them all so
happy
wow i mean seriously gran ki in general
they are a company that supports chess
now their company that wins world
championship titles
great to see that and remind everybody
that they're the
champion they have won the world
corporate
chess championship and we know the first
four teams
they secure seats to participate in
online simul against the winner of the
candidates
i don't think the winner of the
candidates will be very happy to face
these four players
just gonna put like is jan de palmashi
if he
wins the candidate does he play himself
in the in the silence
what kind of agreement is this i feel
bad for the win the cans maybe the
players
don't want to win the candidates anymore
you want to play magnus for the world
championship but
how can you play these people in the
symbol that is that's impossible that's
just
that is just cruel frankly and so they
get the title
and you see that uh the
team that raised the most money for
charity throughout the competition
is invited to the world championship so
it's really great to see this
uh tournament come to a conclusion it
was a big fight
we saw the smiles they were ecstatic as
granka bank beats spare they won one and
a half half in terms of
the individual matches but it was about
the board points they went four and a
half three now that final game
in agres turning around she delivers a
victory when her team needed it
anna that was just awesome that was
awesome these games were so incredibly
exciting and just like
you mentioned before it's not just about
you know board number one
but it's about all the other boards and
here we can see that
inaugures really really brought the win
to to the team here at the end which was
just
absolutely amazing these games i mean
they could not have been more exciting
we've seen so many tactics we've seen so
many
beautiful beautiful games and all of
them had have ended very quickly after
after some nice tactical variation so
it's been an absolute honor to be
able to commentate this with you robert
and just like always
and yeah i really hope that this is not
the last
the last feed online world corporate
chess championship that they do
i don't think it will be it was a
tremendous success and
granted bank we saw them smiling
they clearly have good team chemistry
and
for that team just seriously great stuff
grenkey you'll recognize that name
not just as world champions in the
fide online world corporate chess
championship but also as
sponsors of the grand cake classic which
features the likes of magnus carlsen and
fabiano caruana
and some of the top german players they
are represented in the bundesliga
as well so i mean this is just great
stuff and
you know people have been asking
throughout the tournament and uh
oh is it just bringing grand masters on
teams that doesn't seem right
no the grand master works at grand cay
georg meyer
the top board for this team he works at
granca so did
two of the other very strong players it
was just alina kashlinska that brought
on
that worked to their advantage she's the
free agent she's
under that 2500 threshold you could have
only one player above
she won the final game we saw that
attack with the knight and f5 so anna
clearly good team chemistry good choices
on whom to bring on to the squad
can't congratulate them enough no
absolutely big
big big congrats er to grinky bank for
this
absolutely amazing and just
to see that chemistry at the end to see
everybody smiling
and being so happy it was a beautiful
moment
so can't congratulate them enough either
i'm happy for them i i just was not
rooting for either
team but you saw their they're just joy
and that's always good to see you feels
bad for spare they had
a great showing jana palm she led the
way and
i guess that half point that he at the
end where he let
gary meyer off the hook not that he was
ever winning but he was
just applying the pressure couldn't
quite make the breakthrough bjorg is a
very good defender
and there is pressure on players when
you're that highly rated to win every
single game
i think jan can hold his head high the
whole team can because they just met
their match
in grand cay so through and through that
spare team they beat a very strong spare
bank
trade union in the semi-finals led by
anton korbov
i think that there could only be one
champion but both teams looked equally
deserving
gronky gets on top anna it's been a lot
of fun covering the final with you that
was
exciting we saw some scrambles we saw a
checkmate in the first set of
quarterfinal matches
we had a blitz tie break we it came down
to the very last game it can't get
better
than that you can't get better than that
i completely agree with you
it was so close all the time there
weren't really any
you know big big big 40s or
stuff like that everything was super
close all the time and
yeah i mean super exciting match and the
fact that it
it was all down to the very last match
just made it even better we've been
we've been so so so me and robert we've
been so excited every single match
and we've been having to recover during
the breaks just because the match has
been so exciting
so we couldn't have asked for anything
else that's right
and before we leave i would be remiss
not to thank fide for organizing this
event
for chess.com for being a partner and
putting on the event hosting all the
games
all the arbiters who worked tirelessly
to make sure
that fair play standards were upheld to
make sure the event ran as smoothly
as possible the rounds beginning on time
to everyone behind the scenes putting in
these late hours the nighttime
matchups ended past midnight for plenty
of people or early
started early in the morning if you're
in europe so we know that our producer
up early
working hard behind the scenes everyone
who's watching we appreciate you
the viewership for chess is a sight to
behold
it's great to see the numbers increase
as more people
get involved and finally to the players
this event was not possible without them
cranky bank the champions but so many
teams deserve our
praise and applause and anna again i
really appreciate you joining me
and everybody who was able to donate
thank you so much for your generosity
for helping these initiatives for feed a
for players with disabilities
for veteran players and for education
chess on that note
it's time to sign off anna again
appreciate you
we'll be commenting again soon i'm sure
and it was an absolute blast
yeah definitely definitely thank you
once again for everybody
who organized this event and everybody
behind the scenes
and everybody watching all the players
it's
uh it's it's been an honor to be able to
be here the very last day and to
commentate with you the finals
and yeah i'm sure i'm sure they'll be
commentating more stuff in the future
robert
uh maybe even another corporate
championship but for now
this one's in the books it is the first
one gregor bank the champions
everybody enjoy the rest of day keep
having fun with chess
[Music]
you